THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE- WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY INTO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS OF
SENATORS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES.
WE HAVE VARIOUS REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE ALCOHOL INDUSTRY WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ANSWERED
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE. IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU RECOGNIZE
A SPEAK. A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ANNOY YOU PLEASE SELECT
UNMUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THAT
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC INTO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON YOUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
HE WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-5489 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO THREE FIVE FIVE THREE
FOUR THREE. SAY THAT AGAIN. TWO
THREE FIVE FIVE THREE FOUR THREE
FOR DETAILED AND- INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE
SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
. FOR TODAY'S HEARING WE
BELIEVED WE'LL BE HEARING- ALL
OF THE PANELS OF WITNESSES ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ONCE WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL THE WITNESSES WILL HAVE
A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER TO E.
YOUR FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND AVOID CUSICK FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. ANY INDIVIDUAL'S
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE SERVICE MEETING. IN
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL
EVERY EFFORT IS MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IT IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
WAIT TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS. WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW. USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
EVEN AFTER TWENTY MONTHS. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENCE SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
. I WILL NOW BEGIN WITH OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON DIRECT
TO CONSUMER SHIPPING. AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW EARLIER THIS YEAR
SENATOR ALLEN INTRODUCED SB SIX
TWENTY. WHICH SEEKS TO EXPAND
THE ABILITY OF CERTAIN ALCOHOL
MANUFACTURERS TO SHIP THEIR
PRODUCTS DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS.
AFTER CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND THIS COMMITTEE
THE AUTHOR AGREED TO POSTPONE
THE HEARING THE BILL WITH A
COMMITMENT FROM THIS COMMITTEE
TO HOLD AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON THIS TOPIC. THIS HEARING IS
THAT COMMITMENT. WELL AS P. SIX
TWENTY WAS NOT HEARD DURING THIS
PAST LEGISLATIVE SESSION THE
INTENT FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO
HEAR THE BILL. THE TEN IS FOR
THIS COMMITTEE TO HEAR THE BILL
DURING OUR TWO YEAR BILL HEARING
STARTING IN JANUARY. MY HOPE IS
THAT STAKEHOLDERS AND THE AUTHOR
OF USED THIS PAST YEAR TO WORK
ON THE ISSUE. YEAH I WILL USE
THIS HEARINGS THE FINAL STEPPING
STONE FOR A POSSIBLE COMPROMISE
ON THE BILL. A COUPLE
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS BEFORE WE
BEGIN OUR SPEAKERS. I WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTED TO
PARTICIPATE. TO CALL IN NOW-
WHO'S CALLING NOW OKAY PLEASE
USE A TOLL FREE NUMBER
844-291-5409 AGAIN THE ACCESS
CODE. 235-534-3534 THREE YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNISTIC WHAT'S
ALL THE WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA
SPEAK I JUST WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT'S PROBABLY GONNA BE A WHILE
SO BE PATIENT I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE MEMBERS ARE WHERE THE
YOU WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
QUESTION. THEY ASK QUESTIONS
AFTER EVERY PANEL HE HAD BEEN IN
NOT AFTER EVERY WITNESS I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR SPECIFIC WITNESS
PLEASE JUST WAIT TILL THE ENTIRE
PALES SPOKEN SPEAKING OF
WITNESSES LET ME THANK ALL OF
YOU IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR TIME SIR
ALAN I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A FEW
WORDS. I WANT TO THANK YOU MR
CHAIR THIRTY CENTER DIED AND I
WANT TO THANK THE GEO STAFF. ARE
FOR YOUR DEDICATED WORK ON THIS
ISSUE I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING- ON DIRECT
TO CONSUMER SHIPPING. I HAVE
DISTILLED SPIRITS AND BEER WHICH
WAS AS YOU MENTION THE FOCUS OF
OUR EFFORTS EARLIER THIS YEAR S.
BE SIX TWENTY A BILL THIS- GOING
TO BE BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AND-
IN THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS. I'M
IN ONE OF THE DISTRICT'S BEEN
TERRIBLE PANDEMIC AS WE ALL KNOW
BUT ONE OF THE SILVER LININGS. I
HAS BEEN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CREATIVE POLICY IDEAS SPURRED BY
THE NEED TO ADJUST TO LIFE UNDER
CODE RESTRICTIONS. SINCE AN HOUR
IN A SITUATION WHERE TEN STATES
IN THE COUNTRY AND THE AND THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA ALLOW
DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIPPING FOR
BEER. AND DISTILLED SPIRITS. HI
DURING THE PANDEMIC ADDITIONAL
STATES ALLOWED OFF THE WHOLE
PRODUCERS TO SHIP DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS AS A TEMPORARY
ECONOMIC RELIEF MEASURE- AS
FOLKS HERE KNOW IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY JUST LAST YEAR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM DIRECTED. OUT
DIFFERENT ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
CONTROL ALLOW DIRECT CONSUMER
SIPPING A BEER AND SPIRITS. THIS
IS ONE OF SEVERAL POLICIES WERE
PUT IN PLACE TO RESPOND TO
CONSUMER DEMAND. IN THE SOCIALLY
DISTANT ECONOMY. HOW THE STATE
NOT INTERVENED AND ALLOWED FOR
TEMPORARY ABILITY. FOR DIRECT
CONSUMER SHIPPING. IN THOSE
CASES MANY LOCAL DISTILLERIES
AND BREWERIES- WOULD'VE LIKELY
BEEN FORCED TO SHUT DOWN
PERMANENTLY. SO NOW IT'S MY
SENSE YOU KNOW JUST IN THE SAME
WAY THAT WE'VE NOW SEEN THE
BENEFITS OF ALFRESCO DINING AND
ONE I HOPE TO ENCOURAGE CITIES
TO ENCOURAGE TO CONTINUE THAT
PRACTICE. WE'VE GOT THE
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO SUPPORT THESE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES BY
CREATING A BETTER SYSTEM WHILE
INCREASING CONVENIENCE AND
SAFETY. FOR CUSTOMERS. ALREADY
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW BOTH IN
STATE NOT A STATE WINE GROWERS
ARE ALLOWED TO SELL AND SHIP
WINE DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS.
WE'VE SEEN THE DIRECT TO
CONSUMER MODEL WORK EFFECTIVELY
IN THE WINE MARKET NINE OTHER
STATES IN CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC AND WE KNOW IT'S
WHAT CONSUMERS WANT. I'LL GIVE
YOU A PERSONAL STORY I GOT
MARRIED. SATURNO HEIAU. UNDERDOG
IS A STORY BUT- WE GOT MARRIED
IN A WONDERFUL PART OF OHIO-
THAT- IS FAMOUS FOR ITS
MOONSHINE. AND FOUND A WONDERFUL
LOCAL DISTILLER WHO WANTED TO I
WAS GONNA SERVE AT OUR WEDDING
AND TELL FOLKS ABOUT. HIS
DISTILLERY IN ALL OF HIS WORK
AND- THE CRAZY THING IS AND HE
BEAMED LIVE JUST DOWN THE ROAD
FROM THE PLACE WHERE WE GOT
MARRIED- I WASN'T ABLE TO BUY IT
DIRECTLY FROM HIM WE HAD TO GO
TOGETHER TO THE LOCAL KROGER. TO
BUY BOTTLES OF HIS- OF HIS-
PRODUCT. HI JUST SO SWEET TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE AT THE WEDDING
WHICH IS JUST SO RIDICULOUS
BECAUSE HE HAD A- YOU KNOW A
FIVE. OF IT LIKE A ROOM FULL OF
FOR THE PRODUCT RIGHT THERE IT
IS THAT IS OFFICE THAT HE WAS
HAPPY TO SELL TO ME BUT IT
BECAUSE HE WASN'T ALLOWED TO
BECAUSE- HI I HAVE SIMILAR LAWS
TO WHAT WE HAVE AND IT GOT ME
THINKING A LOT. ABOUT HOW WE
REALLY NEED TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER FOR CONSUMERS. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM INDUSTRY
LEADERS TODAY TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT DIRECT CONSUMERS SHIPPING
HOW WE CAN BUILD ON THE
TEMPORARY PANDEMIC MODEL TO MAKE
IT AN EVERYDAY REALITY. I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN MR KERR
FOR BEING HERE MY COLLEAGUES.
FOR BEING HERE AS WELL. FOR
FURTHER WAYS OF THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SAY ANYTHING BEFORE WE START
. OKAY WE'LL PROCEED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- OKAY WE'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST RESENTER. IT'S
MATTHEW- BODY. BODY HE'S THE
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE
DEPARTMENT ABC. MR BONDING- YOU
CAN BEGIN SIR. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WHEN HE DOES APOLOGIZE
AND- BUT I'M ON A TRAIN BUT ONCE
WE GOT THE ON THE- BIKE GOOD
AFTERNOON THE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANKS
FOR HAVING THE EFFECT. GOD MY
NAME IS MATTHEW VAUGHN AND I AM
THE GENERAL COUNSEL WITH THE
THING. THAT ARE GOING. TO COME
OUT PUBLICLY HELLO. DURING MY
MORE THAN YEARS REGULAR OUT. OR
AND- YUP. TO BECOME FAMILIAR
WITH MANY OF THE ISSUES
SURROUNDING THE SHIPPING ABOUT
PUBLIC RECORDS. ON MANUFACTURED
CROSS STATE LINES. I SPOKE WITH
REGULATORS FROM ANY OTHER STATES
AS WELL AS INDUSTRY AND SHIPPING
COMPANY REPRESENTATIVES. THIS IS
AN INCREDIBLY COMPLEX AREA OF
LAW AND ALCOHOL RECOVERY BUT
MANY COMPETING INTERESTS
STRUGGLING TO BALANCE THE DEVICE
WITH THE INDUSTRY TO EXPAND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES. AND THE
NEED FOR PUBLIC POLICY TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
. MANY STATES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA HAVE THEIR REGULATORY
STRUCTURES CHALLENGED THE
BILLBOARDS. BASED ON
CONSTITUTIONAL OKAY COMMENTS
GROUNDS. THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT HAD SPOKEN
DIRECTLY ON THE ISSUE OF
SHIPPING OUT THE HOPE YOU CREATE
YOUR CROPS THEY WANT. HELP IF
THEY NEED TO SHOW THAT
RESTRICTIONS ON OUT OF STATE
THAT. BUT THEY'RE NOT A FLIGHT
INSPECT THE AND- SUPPORTED BY
JUSTIFY. MAY TO ADVANCE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE LEGITIMATE NON
DISCRIMINATORY REASONS. AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE THE END OF THE
ISSUES INVOLVED A VERY COMPLEX.
MANY THOUGHT. MY GOAL TODAY IS
TO SIMPLY SUMMARIZE WHAT IS
PERMITTED ON THE STRIP AND
CALIFORNIA LAW. SHIPPING AND
DELIVERY ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
THANK YOU BYE BYE. AND STATE AND
OUT OF STATE. YEAH CALIFORNIA
REGULATES THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
INDUSTRY- FOR MODIFIED IT SUCKED
UP. AND IT'S NOT SIMPLE FORM OF
ANY TRUST LAW DEFINES THE
SEPARATE MANUFACTURERS
DISTRIBUTORS AND RETAILERS
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. IN A
COMMERCIAL STRUCTURE OF MEDICAL
RECORDS THAT'S NOT PRIVILEGED TO
SELL ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES PRODUCT
AGREEMENT. MANY DECADES BUT
PROHIBITION THE LEGISLATURE HAS
EXPANDED THE PRIVILEGES OF
MANUFACTURERS TO INCLUDE AMONG
OTHER THINGS THE ABILITY TO SELL
ALCOHOL THEY PRODUCE PRODUCT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT. UNTIL THE
UNITED STATES COURT ISSUED A THE
COLLISION ON THE GRASS HOME
FIELD EXAMS WITHOUT PART. IS
WIDELY UNDERSTOOD BUT UNCLAIMED
MANUFACTURED COULD BE AFFORDED
MORE PRIVILEGES THAT'S RESPECT
OUT OF SPEC AT BERKSHIRE. I
WOULD TO THE COURT COME OUT OF
THE TWENTY FOUR AND THEN WE AND
THE PHONE PROMISE BOOKS. OUT OF
THIRTY NINE AFTER MUSTARD BE A-
FOR PRIVILEGE. I DIDN'T THINK MY. I'M TO SELLING AND DELIVER
ALCOHOL BEVERAGES. THIS PREVENTS
MANY LEGAL REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT AND TAX. LOCAL LOCAL
LOCAL MANUFACTURERS HAVE BEEN
POLITICAL DIRECT TO CONSUMER
ACCESS DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
WINERIES BREWERIES AND
DISTILLERIES AND CREATE SOME OF
THE DELIVERY CODE WHICH IS THE
CLEARLY STATED. ON ALL OF THOSE-
PART. CALIFORNIA WINERIES SO
MANY YEARS AT THE CLUB WITH A
SELL DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS FEEL
BOTTLES OF WINE PER QUANDARY
PRODUCERS WILL HAVE YOUR SUPPORT
. WITH THAT PRIVILEGE I WILL
COMPLY THE NUMBER STILL GONNA
WINERY COULD ALSO. DID YOU KNOW
THE WAY FROM APPLY. AND
THROUGHOUT FIVE FOLLOWING THE
SUPREME COURT DECISION A LITTLE
LATER THE QUESTION CARDS SECTION
THREE THIRTY SIX ONE POINT.
THREE CREATING A WIND DIRECTION
. THE FIRM A PROVIDER
INFORMATION AND OTHER ONE- IT'S
- MY- SHIP AND DELIVER UNLIMITED
QUANTITIES CAUGHT WIND. HELLO I
COULD NOT BE LABELED AS
CONTAINING ALCOHOL AND THE
MANUFACTURER MUST REQUIRE THE
DELIVERY PERSON TO OBTAIN A
SIGNATURE LOOK YEAH TWENTY ONE.
BUT ALL OF OUR- IN ADDITION OUT
OF STATE WINERIES MUST PAY ALL
APPLICABLE CALIFORNIA TRACKS. IN
SOME RESPECTS THE CREATIVE
SITUATIONS IN WHICH OUT OF STATE
WINERIES AND MULTIPLE
DISCIPLINES LIKE WALK. FOR
EXAMPLE A WINERIES MAY ONLY SELL
ONE THEY PRODUCE THEMSELVES OR
THAT PRODUCE FOR THEM ON THE
LINE FOR YOUNG. NO SOONER THAT
PRESCRIPTION IT LOOKS LIKE OUT
OF STATE ONE. IN ADDITION THE
OUT OF STATE WINERIES DO NOT
NECESSARILY HAVE TO SATISFY THE
SAME QUIET. WE CAN QUALIFY A
PARK. SO THIS MEANS OUT OF STATE
BUSINESSES MAY BE ABLE TO SELL
ON THE LEVEL ONE FOR HELLO ON
THE COMPUTER. EVEN ON AN
INSPECTOR OPERATING IN THE SAME
MANNER. WOULD NOT BECOME A
CRITICAL. WHILE CALIFORNIA
BREWERIES AT THE PRIVILEGE TO
TELL OCCUR SOME. TO CONTINUE THE
CONSUMPTION. THE LIGHTNING. J.
B. THREE OF MOTHER PERSONALLY
AUTHORIZE THEM TO SHIP OR TO LET
US THE COMPUTER QUITE A LOT
PERHAPS. HOWEVER INTERPRETED
UNDERSTOOD BUT THE ALSO FROM AND
PRIVILEGE TALK WITH YEAH MOST
THAT YOU APART HELLO PROVIDING
OUT OF STATE OR IS SHIP OR
DELIVER THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CONSUMERS. WELL LET NOT TO
ACROSS SOME OF THE ACTIVE
FIFTEEN. OCTOBER MANUFACTURERS
THAT LIKE THE PRIVILEGE TO TELL
STORY SPIRITS. YOUR WHAT THE
CREATION OF THE CROSS DISTILLERY
LIGHTLY TWENTY. FIVE CRICHTON
BOOK NOW FELL TO THE COURT ON
THE BUT THE THIRD ANNUAL ACTUAL
PRODUCE. WITH A WRECKER THANK
YOU LOOK AT THE LIFE OF ALERT.
THE MAIN CROP THE SELLER THIS
PHILIP HAD LOTION OR TO LOOK
PRIVILEGE AND MY ONLY SELL
COMPUTERS WILL CRASH ON. APPLE I
THINK THE SPORT. IN A- I CROPPED
UP DYLAN LONGER. TO HOLD ONE.
I'M NOT GOING TO AND CRY OF THE
OR- IN FACT A LOT. OF THE CROPS
- BUT- AS YEAH THERE NO SPECIAL
AUTHORITY FOR OUT OF STATE
IMPROVEMENT. SELL SURE WHAT A
LITTLE OF VIOLENCE THERE THE
WRECKAGE. HELLO ON. EIGHTY THREE
CONTROL TO BE A VERY TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS
A FREE MANY COMPETING BUT
ACTUALLY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY BUT BY THE SUMMER.
OKAY THANK YOU MR BONDING I
GUESS- THE FIRST THING OUT IS IT
WAS PRETTY HARD FOR US TO HEAR
IN IN THIS ROOM GIVEN THE
CONNECTIONS I'M NOT SURE WAS AS
HARD TO HEAR FOR OTHER PEOPLE
BUT- THAT'LL BE A SUBJECT OF
DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD- I
THINK WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WILL
JUST A MISTER BODY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING ON WE WOULD
LIKE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HERE AND I AGREE WE'D LIKE TO
GET IF WE GET THE WRITTEN
COMMENTS SO THAT WE CAN. REVIEW
YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY PLEASE.
GOING UP THE CHAIRLIFT AND GET
THOSE OVER TO YOU RIGHT AWAY.
THANK YOU SIR. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO TAKE MR TIM SCHMELZER-
WITH THE- WINE INSTITUTE THE
SMELTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. PLEASED TO BE HERE-
CHURN MEMBERS AND- REALLY- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY- I WAS
ASKED TO KIND OF SHARE WITH THE
EXPERIENCES. OF CALIFORNIA
WINERIES WITH REGARD TO OUR
PRIVILEGE OF BEING ABLE TO SHIP
DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS- AS AS I
KNOW YOUR PARTICULAR WHERE-
GERMAN DIED- OUR INDUSTRY IS IT
IS PROBABLY AN INTEGRAL PART OF.
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURAL FABRIC
STANDS. THE DIRECT TO CONSUMER
PRIVILEGE IS A VITAL PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S WINE BUSINESS AND
IS A COMPLIMENT TO OUR
TRADITIONAL RETAIL CHANNELS.
DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHOULD BEING
ALLOWS CALIFORNIA WINERIES AND
OTHER WONDERS OF COURSE TO
MAINTAIN A PERSONAL CONNECTION
WITH OUR CUSTOMERS BY PROVIDING
THEM A UNIQUE EXPERIENCE ARE YOU
PROBABLY NOTED THAT- IF YOU EVER
VISIT A WINERY THAT NEARLY EVERY
WINERY HOUSE OF WINE CLUB. ADD
THIS WINE CLUBS ARE- THROUGH
THIS PRIVILEGE ABLE TO SHIP
UNIQUE BOTTLINGS TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS ON A SUBSCRIPTION
BASIS THIS IS OFTEN THE BREAD
AND BUTTER- OF REVENUE FOR- IN
PARTICULAR THE SMALLER WONDERS-
WINERIES. ARE HAVE A STRONG
EMPHASIS ON HOSPITALITY ALMOST
ALL WINERIES ARE LOCATED IN. A
COLLEGE SETTING SURROUNDED BY
VINEYARDS AND HAVE THESE
BEAUTIFUL TASTING ROOMS. AND
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
UNIQUE EXPERIENCE DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMER'S STORES REALLY HELPS
FOSTER- THAT PERSONAL CONNECTION
WE HAVE WITH OUR CUSTOMERS. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT REALLY MAKES
DIRECT TO CONSUMER WORK IS ITS
COMPLEMENT TO WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO
PUT IN A RETAIL CHANNELS.
WINERIES ARE ABLE TO MAKE
DIFFERENT STYLES OF WINE- EVERY
YEAR IN ORDER TO PROVIDE UNIQUE
SMALL BATCH. WINES FOR THEIR
CUSTOMERS- THAT THEY TYPICALLY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO GET IN THE
GROCERY STORE OR OR OTHER PLACES
ALLOWS OUR WINEMAKERS TO REALLY
LEAD INTO THE ARTISTRY OF WINE
MAKING AND THEY CAN CREATE
UNIQUE BLENDS. I AM DIFFERENT-
BRIDLES AND MIXING BLENDING
DIFFERENT VARIETALS AS WELL AS A
FIND DIFFERENT TECHNIQUES SUCH
AS BARREL AGING YOU SERVE
DIFFERENT USE SENATE CETERA TO
PROVIDE. UNIQUE EXPERIENCES FOR
THE CUSTOMER AND THIS IS WHAT
REALLY FUELS OUR CUSTOMERS
DESIRE TO HAVE WIND SHIFT
DIRECTLY IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY WOULDN'T OTHERWISE BE ABLE
TO GET. NO DOUBT ALSO BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE THESE ARE SMALL BATCH
WINES WITH THE HIGH FOCUS ON
PREMIUM QUALITY HAS REALLY LED
TO- AN OVERALL IMPROVEMENT IN
THE QUALITY OF WINES SICK-
CALIFORNIA WINERIES HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO PRODUCE OVER THE YEARS-
BETTER STILL ONLY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT EVERY
SEGMENT OF OUR- INDUSTRY
BENEFITS FROM. THE DIRECT TO
CONSUMER- WHITE PRIVILEGE EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NORMALLY ASSOCIATED
JUST WITH SMALL WIRES. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT MEANS TO CONNECT
WITH CUSTOMERS AND MAKE A
PERSONAL CONNECTION EVEN FOR OUR
OUR LARGEST WINERIES. AND ALLOWS
THEIR THEIR WINE MAKERS JUST AS
WELL AS SMALL WINE- WINERY
WINEMAKERS. PRODUCE UNIQUE
BOTTLE IT'S- M. FOR SMALL
WINERIES I AM FRANKLY DIRECT TO
CONSUMER IT IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL TO THEIR SURVIVAL.
WELL OVER 90% OF CALIFORNIA'S
FOUR THOUSAND WINERIES ARE
EXTREMELY SMALL AND SHE MORE OR
LESS TOTALLY DEPENDENT ON DIRECT
TO CONSUMER SALES. WHETHER THIS
IS OUT THERE TASTING ROOMS OR BY
SHIFTING DIRECTLY TO THE
CONSUMERS STORE. IN FACT THIS
DIRECT TO CONSUMER PRIVILEGE HAS
REALLY FOSTERED THE GROWTH OF
SMALL BOUTIQUE WINERIES IN
CALIFORNIA AFTER THE LANDMARK
TWO THOUSAND FIVE GRAND HOME
SEASON. THE THIS SEGMENT OF THE
WINE INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA HAS HAS
LITERALLY EXPLODED TO THE POINT-
LIKE I MENTONED WE HAVE ALMOST
FOUR THOUSAND WINERIES IN
CALIFORNIA. ARE ALSO IMPORTANT
TO NOTE ON AND IT'S- BUT I THINK
SENATOR ALLEN BROUGHT THIS UP-
THIS ABILITY TO SHIP DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS- WAS A VITAL LIFELINE
FOR SMALL LINERS TO SURVIVE
DURING THAT. ACADEMIC THEY'D
LITERALLY WHATEVER HI JUST IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN UGLY OUT THERE
MANY WINERIES WHAT ABOUT TO SHUT
SHUT THEIR DOORS- BUT FOR THE
STABILITY AND IT REALLY. I JUST
CAN'T EMPHASIZE HOW IMPORTANT
THAT WAS TO THEIR SURVIVAL.
DURING DURING THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES- IT ALSO- CREATED SHOULD
LEAD TO SOME NEW CREATIVE
APPROACHES TO SELLING WINE- THAT
AGAIN LIKE CINDERELLA MENTIONED
I GUESS- NOW IT IS VERY COMMON
FOR WINERIES OFFER VIRTUAL WINE
TASTINGS. FOR EXAMPLE WHERE YOU
HAVE ONE SHIPPED DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMER THEY WILL GET ONLINE
MUCH LIKE WE ARE TODAY AND THE-
WINEMAKER OR PERHAPS TO GET SOME
OF THE ACTION WALK THEM THROUGH-
THE TASTINGS AND GIVE THEM-
EXPERIENCE VERY SIMILAR TO BEING
ABLE TO VISIT THE WIND. BY
WINERY DIRECTLY. ALSO I WAS
ASKED TO SPEAK LITTLE BIT AS TO
THE LOGISTICS ABOUT HOW DIRECT
TO CONSUMER- WHEN SHIPPING WORKS
FOR WINERIES. FOR MOST WINERIES%
THE NORMAL APPROACH IS TO USE-
TO HANDLE THIS PRIVILEGE THROUGH
THE USE OF TWO DIFFERENT- TYPES
OF THIRD PARTY COMPANIES. THE
FIRST IS ESSENTIALLY A
COMPLIANCE COMPANY THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING
APPROPRIATE LICENSES- ARE IN
PLACE AND TAXES ARE ARE
COLLECTED- CAUSES I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
ABHORRENT OF. WINE SHIPPING LAWS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT MUST BE
NAVIGATED. FRANKLY BEYOND THE
ABILITY OF MOST SMALL WINERIES
TO DO THAT THEMSELVES- AND IT'S
FOR EXACTLY THAT REASON THAT
THESE ARE COMPANIES EXIST. AND
ALSO OF COURSE TAX RATES BERRY-
YOU KNOW NOT ONLY IN OBVIOUSLY
CALIFORNIA- JURISDICTIONS BUT
ALSO ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE TAKE
VERY SERIOUSLY- OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO COLLECT THE
APPROPRIATE TAXES AND THE USE OF
THESE TOP INSULTS INSURE. THAT
APPROPRIATE TAXES ARE COLLECTED
AND REMITTED TO THE PROPER
AUTHORITIES. AND THEN- THE OTHER
PROBABLYWOULD ALREADY GUESSED
BUT- FULFILLMENT CENTER SO MOST
WINERIES- USE ONE OF TWO LARGE
FULFILLMENT- COMPANIES- THAT ARE
LOCATED IN THE STATE. AND WHEN
YOU HAVE A WIDE ORDER IT'S
USUALLY- THAT COMPANIES HOUSE
WRIST IS STORING PRODUCT FROM
THE WINERIES AND CANDLES. ARE
ACTUALLY PACKING AND SHOULD BE
IN THAT WIND- TRUE THE CONSUMER
AND THAT'S A COUPLE. MOMENT
SECTORS. AND THEN- FOR. I WAS
ASKED SPEAK A LITTLE ABOUT TWO
BE. BALL OF WINE TALKING ABOUT
OR WHAT WHAT PERCENTAGES OF THE
INDUSTRY. AND THE NUMBERS
ACTUALLY QUITE QUITE SMALL AND-
IN REGARDS TO THE OVERALL-
BUYING SALES. DIRECT TO
CONSUMER- SHIPPING- WINE AS A
PERCENTAGE OF TOTAL ONE THAT
ENTERS THE MARKET PLACE IS ONLY
TWO POINT 2% OF THE STOCK
ACTUALLY RELATIVELY SMALL. BUT
YOU ALSO HAVE TO PUT THAT IN
CONTEXT IS THE LIFEBLOOD OF WELL
OVER 90% OF A VERY VERY SMALL
AND- WINERIES THAT THEMSELVES
ACCOUNT FOR JUST A SMALL AMOUNT
OF THE MARKETPLACE- TO PUT A
REAL NOW. TWO FOR YOU-
CALIFORNIA- SHIPMENTS ACCOUNT
FOR ABOUT 77% OF THE TOTAL U. S.
DIRECT TO CONSUMER MARKET. AND
THAT COMES OUT TO ABOUT FIVE
MILLION CASES OF CALIFORNIA WINE
THAT IS SHIPPED DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS- INTERESTINGLY WITH
THAT- TWO POINT TWO. PERCENT
NUMBER- IT ACTUALLY ACCOUNTS
413% OF THE VALUE. OF THE- WINE
THAT'S PUT INTO CONSUMER
CHANNELS AND THIS REALLY
REFLECTS THAT UP PARTICIPANTS IN
THE H. R. DIRECT TO CONSUMER-
MARKETS ARE SEEKING A UNIQUE AN
OP AND- PREMIUM WINE EXPERIENCE
SO- FOR THE MOST PART- THESE ARE
FOLKS THAT ARE INTERESTED IN YOU
KNOW YOU NEED. A HIGH END
BOTTLES OF WINE EACH OTHER THIS
NOTABLY- DURING THE PANDEMIC
YOUR- THERE'S BEEN SOME
RELATIVELY SEISMIC SHIFTS. IT
NOT MARKET OUR OUR CONSUMERS ARE
FINE WITH THAT FINDING THAT
DIRECT TO CONSUMER MAYBE THE
ONLY MANNER IN WHICH THEY CAN-
THEY CAN GET THEIR HANDS ON SOME
WINDS. AND THERE'S BEEN SORT OF
A CALL A CORRESPONDING INCREASE
IN DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIPMENTS-
WITH THE REDUCTION IN A WINERY
VISITATIONS. I'M NOT SURE WE DO
TOO- PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS-
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE IF THAT BEARS
OUT OVER TIME- ALONG WITH THAT-
I THINK- YOU FOLKS SEE IN SOME
ECONOMIC HARD TIMES- THE VALUE.
OF THE WIND HAS. HAS NOT GONE
DOWN SLIGHTLY AS THE OVERALL
PERCENTAGE- BUT ANYWAY IT'S
STILL BEEN ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
PART OF OUR OF OUR INDUSTRY AND-
IT'S A PRIVILEGE THAT WE- INTEND. TO HOLD ON TO. AS FOR A- AND-
WE HOPE- WE ONLY MORE GROWTH IN
THE END ON IT- IS ABLE TO HELP-
WINERIES THROUGHOUT TELL AND
INSPIRED AND TO ANY QUESTIONS.
OUR MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR FOR ANYBODY ON THIS
PANEL. SEVERAL THANK YOU SO MUCH
TO HIM THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND- SEEMS LIKE WORDS
OF TELLING RELLY NICELY I JUST
WANTED TO- I WANTED TO JUST KIND
OF POINT GET A DENTIST TO
SPECIFICALLY I WAS SO INTERESTED
IN THIS THIS ISSUE OF MISSION
SPECIALIZED PROJECT PRODUCTS
BECAUSE IT I THINK IT REALLY
DOES SPEAK TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
OR TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE. AND
YOU KNOW THE END OF THE DAY FOR
SOME OF THEM ARE MASS PRODUCED
PRODUCTS THAT THAT ARE THAT ARE
THAT ARE YOU THAT THAT THAT
GENERATE INTEREST IN THE GENERAL
PUBLIC THE STATUS QUO MAY BE
FINE BUT- BUT IT BUT IT'S IF YOU
CAN- CAN BE VERY FRUSTRATING FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT SOMETHING THAT'S
NOT AS WELL KNOWN- AND THEN
THEY'RE NOT REALLY ABLE TO GET
IT BECAUSE THE YOU KNOW THE
FOLKS WHO ARE NOW IN CHARGE OF.
THE DISTRIBUTION JUST DON'T HAVE
A MARKET IS NOT ENOUGH OF A
MARKET FOR THEM TO. TAKE ON THE
PRODUCTS SO CAN YOU CAN YOU TALK
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT TO SERVE
NEESON SPECIALIZED PRODUCTS AND
ALSO HOW. HOW DID DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SUPPORTS THE QUALITY OF
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS TO YOU
MENTION THAT AS WELL I'D LOVE
YOU TO. TO JUST EXPAND UPON YEAH
I GUESS WHY IT MY MAJOR POINT
THERE WAS- YOU KNOW OUR
EXPERIENCES TAUGHT US. THAT
PEOPLE PARTICIPATE IN DIRECT TO
CONSUMER NOT NOT OUT OF.
CONVENIENCE IT'S FRANKLY IT'S-
MORE CONVENIENT FOR MOST PEOPLE
TO GO TO THIS. STORE BECAUSE OF
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD RIGHT OVER A
TRAIN BUT THEY THEY SEEK IT OUT
BECAUSE THEY CAN GET A UNIQUE
PRODUCT THAT THEY WOULDN'T
OTHERWISE. BEABLE TO GET. AND
IT'S FOR THAT REASON- YOU KNOW
THAT THE WINERIES HAVE- YOU KNOW
REALLY SOUGHT TO CREATE UNIQUE
PRODUCTS THAT- WOULD. WOULD SORT
OF JUSTIFY CONSUMERS INTEREST
YOU KNOW AND- AND PARTICIPATING
IN THE IN THEIR DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS. YEAH SO- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE SOME WINERIES WHERE. YOU
KNOW. I'M I'M MAKING UP NUMBERS
THE STATE- BUT YOU KNOW LIKE 90%
OF THEIR PRODUCTS- THE GOES INTO
RETAIL MARKETS MIGHT EITHER
CABERNET SAUVIGNON AND THEIR-
AND THEIR CHARDONNAY. AND YOU
KNOW NOT. FRANKLY PAYS MOST OF
THE BILLS- FOR THAT WINERY- BUT
THEN THEY PRODUCE MAYBE. TWENTY
OTHER DIFFERENT WINES IN VERY
SMALL BATCHES. PRINCIPALLY FOR
FOLKS THAT EITHER VISIT- THEY'RE
TASTY ROOMS DIRECTLY OR
PARTICIPATE IN THE WINE CLUBS
AND- YOU KNOW IT'S A REAL- IT'S
HIGHSMITH SHOULD JOIN THE WINE
CLUB THAT YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW
FRANKLY YOU CAN GET A WHY NOBODY
ELSE DOES. RIGHT SO. AND I THINK
THIS IS ALLOWED WINEMAKERS TO
EXPERIMENT AND- CREATE UNIQUE
PLANS AND AS A RESULT OF THAT
REALLY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CREATE
BETTER AND BETTER WINDS.
OVERTIME I DIDN'T WORK. AT ALL
TIME HIGH FOR CALIFORNIA WINE
QUALITY AND I'M SURE THIS HA A. LOT TO DO WITH THAT. HAS THERE
BEEN ANY I'M- BELIEVING ME ON
THE OBVIOUS OF HOW. TO CONSUMERS
HAVE AS X. NOW INTER TOPIC GROWN
. FOR YOUR FIRST OBVIOUSLY BEEN
SOME INTEREST IN. WELL THE SO
FOR THE TWO WITH WHAT HOW LAWS.
COURSES THAT EACH STATE HOUSE
TO. PASS LAWS TO. ALLOW FOR
WHITES TO BE SHIPPED INTO THEIR
STATE- AND MR BODY WAS STARTED
DESCRIBING HOW THAT WORKS- I
HAVE COLLEAGUES THAT WORK ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. OTHER
REMARKABLE JOB OF OPENING UP
THIS EXPERIENCE FOR FOLKS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. THIS S REALLY
FOSTERED A TOURISM WINE TOURISM-
FROM FOLKS ARE ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO ARE EXCITED TO.
VISIT CALIFORNIA WINERIES AND
EVEN WHEN THEY GET HOME. THEY
CAN BRING THAT EXPERIENCE BACK
WITH. SO ABSOLUTELY. ALL RIGHT
THANKS MR BODY ARE YOU STILL ON
THE LINE. OKAY THE WELL THEN WHY
DON'T WE GO TO CENTER WAY SO
HE'S QUESTION FOR- MISTER
SMELTER POLICE. YES THANK YOU
NOT I WANTED JUST TO CLARIFY IN
TERMS OF HOW FAR THE BILL
ACTUALLY- CAN BE APPLIED.
BECAUSE I KNOW WE HAVE SOME
LIMITATIONS FOR EXAMPLE OF.
CALIFORNIA THE OUTSIDE VENDORS
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES AND EVEN OUTSIDE
OF CALIFORNIA IN CANADA AND
MEXICO PURCHASE. WHAT PRODUCT
THE PURCHASE BREAK GRAPES OR
JUICE AND THEY TURN THAT INTO A
GRAPE AND IT BECOMES THEIR
GRAPES IN THEIR COUNTRY. AND WE
OFTEN HAVE LIMITATIONS IN TERMS
OF HOW MUCH WE CAN BRING IT TO
THE COUNTRY IN THE UNITED STATES
. AND I WANTED TO ASK THE DIRECT
TO CONSUMER. HOW DOES THAT APPLY
TO CANADA OTHER STATES I MEAN IT
APPLIES TO OTHER STATES IN
AMERICA DOES NOT GO OUTSIDE OF.
CALIFORNIA MEXICO COLOR CANADA
IN TERMS OF- WHAT HOW- THE LA
LAW COULD SPUR CONSUMERS IN
ACCESSING WINES FROM. OF THE
REGION OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA. I
AM EMBARRASSING ONLY NOT ABLE TO
ANSWER THAT I- JUST NOT AS
FAMILIAR WITH THE APPLICABILITY
OF THIS PRIVILEGE- OUT OF THE
COUNTRY- ARE YOU HAPPY TO GET
BACK TO YOU ABOUT I'M SORRY
SOMETHING THAT SOMETHING I
SHOULD KNOW IT WASN'T A QUESTION
I PREPARED FOR AND SO MAYBE YOU
CAN ANSWER- IT APPLIES TO-
STATES OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND SO HOW WOULD
THAT WORK PRACTICALLY A FIND AS
I THE CONSUMER HOW WOULD I
PARTICIPATE. IN THE APPLICATION
OF THIS NEW LAW- WELL OBVIOUSLY
FOR WINE THIS IS AN EXISTING
LAW- SO- YOU KNOW I CAN'T REALLY
SPEAK TO. SENATOR ALAN STILL
BUT- WITH REGARD. NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS YOU COULD HAVE
WIND SHIFT YOU DIRECTLY- YOU
COULD JUST YOU KNOW IF YOU WORK
FROM. YOU KNOW COLORADO OR
WHATEVER AND YOU CAME TO VISIT
NAPA VALLEY YOU ENJOYED THE
WIND. THAT ONE OF THE WINERIES
YOU VISITED SIGNED UP FOR THEIR
WINE CLUB. ON A SUBSCRIPTION
BASIS ARE YOU KIND OF WINE-
DELIERED DIRECTLY TO YOUR
DOORSTEP EVERY QUARTER MIND YOUR
WHATEVER YOU KNOW SHE CAPTIONED
YOU CHOSE. ALTERNATIVELY YOU
COULD YOU KNOW CALL THE WINERY
OR OR GET ONLINE AND ORDER
BOTTLES TO BE SHIPPED DIRECTLY
TO YOU. BUT THERE ARE MANY LONG
IS THAT STATES HAVE LAWS THAT
ALLOWED FOR AS YOU KNOW THERE'S
ACTUALLY HAS TO BE RECIPROCITY
BETWEEN TWO STATE TROOPERS TO
ALLOW BUT THAT'S THOSE ARE THE
LAWS THAT MY COLLEAGUES. HAVE
BEEN WORKING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND- SOMETHING LIKE 99% OF-
ENOUGH AGAIN MAKING UP NUMBERS
BUT OF. AMERICANS ARE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS. SO I
THINK WOULD CENTERS GETTING TO
MR SMALL. IF WE HAVE A IF WE
HAVE A WALLETS WRISTLETS BECAUSE
IT IS CURRENT LAW THAT WENT ON
ONLINE IN THE UNITED STATES IN
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TODAY. SO ASSUMING THAT THE LAWS
ARE OKAY IN OTHER STATES. OR
EVEN OTHER COUNTRIES THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM. TO GO DIRECT TO
CONSUMER IS THERE ANY
PROHIBITION- AGAINST WIND COMING
IN FROM OTHER STATES OR OTHER
COUNTRIES. I DON'T THINK SO BUT
THAT'S WHAT I SAID I WISH I DO
THE DIRECT ANSWER I'VE I'VE
WATCHED AND OBSERVE AMERICA'S I
DON'T- I'M HAPPY TO SAY GET THAT
INFORMATION HERE. SO IN THE
EXAMPLE OF COLORADO- HUH YOU
DON'T KNOW WHETHER THERE'S A
LIMIT I COULD ORDER CASES-
PALLETS OF WINE AS A CONSUMER.
THERE ARE ART SHAPES DIFFERENT
STATES HAVE DIFFERENT RULES AND
THIS IS THIS IS PART OF WHAT I
WAS SPEAKING WITH WITH- TOO WITH
THIS SORT OF LABYRINTH. OF RULES
OUT THERE SO SOME STATES MAY
ONLY ALLOW FOR ONE OR TWO CASES.
OF WINE- A YEAR AND BUT THEY
HAVE TO HAVE SIMILAR LAWS
APPLIED TO THEIR IN STATE.
WINERIES ABILITY AS WELL SO-
THOSE LAWS DON'T COUNT
CALIFORNIA ALLOWS FOR UNLIMITED
BUT OTHER STATES. HAVE DIFFERENT
LAWS AND THOSE LAWS. DON'T
TRIGGER FEDERAL TRADE. LOS AT
THE- NOT A LAWYER BUT- YOU KNOW
THIS PRIVILEGE WAS ESSENTIALLY-
WHY NOT- YOU KNOW IN A SUPREME
COURT CASE THAT- THAT- WAS
FOLLOWED THROUGH- IN DEALING
WITH THE INTERSTATE COMMERCE
ISSUES MR BODY WAS WORDS TRYING
TO SPEAK TO THAT AND IS MUCH
MORE QUALIFIED TO THAT ITEMS. WE
COULDN'T HEAR HIS SPEECH SO THEY
HAVE. OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SORRY I COULDN'T ABOUT ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING TO CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU TERRA DOT- I'M SORRY I
WALKED IN A LITTLE LATE SO
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVEN'T DISCUSSED
THIS BUT I'M JUST A LITTLE
CURIOUS I KNOW THAT. WITH THE
QUARANTINE OF COAL FED DOT
ONLINE SALES HAVE EXPLODED INTO
A LOT OF BUSINESSES ARE DOING
REALLY WELL AND IT MY NOT BE A
FAIR QUESTION WHEN I'M OUT SINCE
YOU'RE NOT DOING IT NOW BUT I'M
JUST WONDERING IF YOU'VE- DELVED
INTO AN ANALYSIS OF MAYBE OTHER
STATES OTHER COUNTRY TEST TO SEE
WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE IN
TERMS OF SALES AND I. IN MY MIND
I'M JUST THINKING ABOUT HOW
DETRIMENTAL COLBERT HAS BEEN TO
SOME OF OUR BUSINESSES AND HOW
IT WOULD HELP THEM. IN TERMS OF
SALES AND FOR OUR STATE HE NOT
TAX DOLLARS IS THERE ANY TYPE OF
ANALYSIS THAT YOU CAN PROVIDE
FOR US TO SEE YOU KNOW THE
BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIA TO THE
ACTUAL BUSINESS OWNERS X. CETERA
. BYE BYE I TRY TO STICK IT OUT
A LITTLE BIT EARLIER I THINK
THAT THIS ABILITY TO- SHIPPED
DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS WAS
ABSOLUTELY A LIFELINE ESPECIALLY
FOR SMALLER WINERIES- THROUGH
THIS PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS-
HOWEVER- I. I THINK SALES
OVERALL- OUT OF THE SMALLER ONE
SECTORS- WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY.
DOWN THIS WAS MORE OF A LIFELINE
AND THEN AT THE END WELCOME YOU
KNOW A BOON. RETAIL SALES ACT
ACTUALLY- DID INCREASE SO IF YOU
WERE IF YOU WERE SELLING INTO
RETAIL CHANNELS- YOU ACTUALLY.
HAVE THE OPTION TO EXPERIENCE
GROWTH THAT I'M I'M SURE YOU
KNOW DIFFERENT LINERS ARE GONNA
HAVE. DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES BUT
THE INABILITY TO- PROVIDE DIRECT
HOSPITALITY OUT WINERIES- YOU
KNOW IT'S A DATA DEVASTATING
IMPACT ON ON A LOT OF SMALLER
WINERIES. AND BUT FOR THIS
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO SHIP ON
DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS. WE WOULD
HAVE SEEN SCORES AND SCORES OF.
WINERIES- SHUT THEIR DOORS.
RIGHT AND- THANK YOU. THEY WERE.
VERY HI MICHELLE SIR- DO YOU
HAVE ANY IDEA HOW MUCH WINE IS
SHIPPED EVERY YEAR IN CALIFORNIA
. JUST THE AMOUNT OF WINE SHIFT.
MIGHT HELP GOTTEN ONE WE SEE I
WONDER IF YOU SHIFT TO LIKE TO
CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS YES- IT IS
THANKS. APPROXIMATELY TWO
MILLION SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE CASES TO PROTECT A
BOTTLE. YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT
ABOUT- A LITTLE OVER TWO POINT
THREE- THE MILLION CASES OF WINE
WERE SHIPPED DIRECTLY TO CONTEST
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS THIS IS
THIS IS THE NUMBER- FROM- TWENTY
TWENTY AND WAS SIGNIFICANTLY-
UP. ALMOST ALMOST 20% AND BACK
OVER THE PREVIOUS YEAR WHICH IS
DUE ALMOST CERTAINLY TO NOT
BEING ABLE TO SELL DIRECTLY ON
PROMISES STOP WINERY. WHETHER
THAT'S ABOUT THAT'S LITTLE OVER
2% OF TOTAL SALES. IS MY BEST
UNDERSTANDING. QUITE RIGHT YET
TWO POINT TWO ZERO YEAH THERE'S
LIKE A THERE'S- SOMETHING BUY IT
AT THAT THIS IS A U. DOES THE
UNITED STATES BUT YOUR BUT IT
CAN BE INTERPRETED BACK
CALIFORNIA THERE'S ABOUT. THREE
HUNDRED MILLION CASES OF WINE
THAT THAT ENTER THE MARKET PLACE
EVERY YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES
ABOUT TWO POINT 2% OF THAT
STRUCTURE CONSUMER. AT WICHITA
FROM CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTS IT
TRANSLATES INTO ABOUT FIVE
MILLION CASES AND DIRECTLY TO
CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS. A LITTLE
OVER TWO POINT THREE MILLION
CASES SO YOU KNOW ABOUT HALF OF
THAT GOES TO A CALIFORNIA
CUSTOMERS THE OTHER HALF
CONSULTS FOR. IT DO YOU SEE I
GUESS I'VE I THINK SOME
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN BROUGHT TO
ME TO ADDRESS ARE. YOU HOW THE
TAXES ARE COLLECTED WHEN WINE IS
SHIPPED BOTH TO THE CONSUMER IN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES IN.
THE JUST YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
NOBODY WANTS LEAKAGE OF THOSE-
YELLED TAXES IF THEY HAVE TO PAY
THOSE TAXES- AT THE RETAIL THEY
SHOULD PAY THEM AT THE- DIRECT
TO CONSUMER I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY'S ARGUING. THAT POINT
BUT IS THERE A LEAKAGE IS THAT
AN ISSUE RIGHT NOW THAT'S BEEN
NOTICED IN. THE DTC FOR WINE-
TRIP CERTAINLY- NOT AN R. X.
THAT'S I REFER TO OUR- THAT'S-
WINERIES ARE ALMOST. ALL OF THEM
. A SPECIALIZED. WHO ARE. OUR
DIRECT RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING
TAXES ARE PAID AND THEN LICENSES
APPROPRIATE LICENSES ARE HELD.
AND YOU KNOW YOU. IF YOU DON'T
DO THIS YOU RISK YOUR LICENSE
YOUR ABILITY TO DO BUSINESS THAT
WE REJECT THIS VERY SERIOUSLY
AND IT'S- YOU KNOW FOR THESE
REASONS. WE USE THESE NEW
SERVICES. SORRY I MISSED WHAT I
DIDN'T HAVE I THINK MY- MY PHONE
ON TO THAT STRONG INSURANCE FOR
THE INTEGRITY OF THE PROGRAM
YEAH ABSOLUTELY ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
SMELTER MISSED MR BODY IF YOU'RE
STILL ON THE LINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR BEING WITH US TODAY
WILL NOW MOVE FORWARD. NOT TO
THE FOLLOWING PANEL WILL BEGIN
WITH MR ALEX- BILL CONNOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ARTIST ARTISANAL
GUILD. MR BILL CONNOR YOU CAN
BEGIN. ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
WRITE YOUR DADA CENTER ALLEN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
ALEX AVILA KHAN AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ARTISANAL DISTILLERS GUILD GUILD
I MADE UP OF A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
CRAFT DISTILLERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I'M I HAVE A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN A SMALL
WINERY OWNER AND WINEMAKER
DISTILLER. OWNER FOR TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS AND STARTED A CRAFT
DISTILLERY INSIDE OF MY WINERY
TEN YEARS AGO. BUT IF YOU'RE
PAST REBELS ON CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL COAST. SO I DEAL WITH A
LOT OF THE REGULATIONS YOU WERE
JUST DISCUSSING WHETHER IT'S YOU
KNOW FILING PAPERS SHIPPING AND
ALL OF THAT STUFF SO I
DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND THE NEW
WANTS. MY EXPERIENCE IN BOTH
INDUSTRIES GAVE ME FIRST HAND
KNOWLEDGE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
DIRECT CONSUMER SHIPPING FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS. MY EXPERIENCE
ALSO GIVES ME THE PERSPECTIVE
NOW THE DTC LET DTC LEGISLATION
WILL BENEFIT ALL STAKEHOLDERS
THE DISTILLERS WHOLESALERS
RETAILERS AND LABOR. CONSUMERS
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
ALCOHOL DTT DTC CONVERSATIONS
NOT NEW AND WE HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF HINDSIGHT IN THAT WE CAN LOOK
AT THE IMPACT THAT DTC HAS HAD
ON THE CALIFORNIA WINE INDUSTRY.
FOR THE PAST THREE DECADES.
PRIOR TO NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
WINERIES ARE IN THE SAME
SITUATION A CRAFT DISTILLERY
SPACE TODAY. DTC LEGISLATION FOR
WINERIES CREATED A FINANCIAL
BOON FOR ALL STAKEHOLDERS WHILE
POSITIONING CALIFORNIA AS A
LEADER IN THE U. S. WIND
INDUSTRY. IT WILL DO THE SAME
FOR DISTILLERIES. HERE THE
NUMBERS ACCORDING TO BOTH WINE
INSTITUTE AND SHIP COMPLIANT A
COMPANY THAT DOES A LOT OF THE-
REPORTING THAT- WE WERE TAUGHT
JUST TALKING ABOUT. AND HOW
DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIPPING FOR
CALIFORNIA WINES ENDED UP
BENEFITING EVERYONE. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX THERE WERE SEVEN
HUNDRED WINERIES PRODUCING
APPROXIMATELY FIVE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF WINE IN
CALIFORNIA. NOW AS WE MENTIONED
THERE'S FOUR THOUSAND WINERIES
IN THE STATE PRODUCING CLOSE TO
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
WINE. WINERIES PRODUCE A FIFTY
SEVEN POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
CALIFORNIA. WINERIES GENERATES
SEVEN POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
IN CALIFORNIA AND LOCAL TAXES.
WINERIES CURRENTLY EMPLOYED
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS. AS WE
LOOK AT CALIFORNIA'S CRAFT
DISTILLING INDUSTRY TODAY WE ARE
AT THE INFANCY STAGE LIKE WINE
WAS IN THE EIGHTIES. WITHOUT PTC
LEGISLATION CRAFTERS DEALERS
ONLY HAVE TWO PATHS TO MARKET
JUST LIKE WINERIES DID BEFORE
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX BOTH
PATTISON POSTS HUGE BARRIERS TO
ENTRY. THE FIRST IS FOR
DISTILLERY TO PURCHASE AROUND
EFFICIENTLY IN A HIGH TRAFFIC
AREA WHERE CONSUMERS CAN VISIT
AND PURCHASED THEIR SPIRITS THE
TASTING ROOM. AND EVEN THE COSTA
CALIFORNIA REAL ESTATE AND THE
CURRENT LAW THAT LIMITS CONSUMER
PURCHASES TO TWO POINT TWO FIVE
LITERS PER PERSON PER DAY THIS
PATH POSES ENORMOUS FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES. FOR SMALL START UP
BRANDS LIKE MY OWN. THE SECOND
PATH TO MARKET FOR DISTILLERIES
THROUGH THE THREE TIER
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM WHICH ALSO
POSES HUGE OBSTACLES FOR SMALL
UNDER CAPITALIZED DISTILLERIES.
WHOLESALERS HAVE THOUSANDS OF
BRANDS MOST WITH MULTIPLE
PRODUCTS THEREFORE TO GENERATE
THE NUMBER OF CASES TO BE
PROFITABLE THROUGH DISTRIBUTION
IS CAPITAL INTENSIVE AND ALSO
CHALLENGING IF THERE'S NO BRAND
RECOGNITION. OR SALES FORCE TO
HELP SUPPORT IT IN THE
MARKETPLACE. THEREFORE
DISTRIBUTION IS NOT GEARED FOR
THE SMALL INDEPENDENT CRAFT
DISTILLERS LIKE ME THAT ARE
OWNED AND OPERATED A BASIC
FUNDING IT WITH A DREAM AND HARD
WORKING A BANK LOAN. MOST
CALIFORNIA DISTILLERS WOULD LOVE
TO EVENTUALLY PARTNER WITH
DISTRIBUTORS BUT NEED TO
INCREASE SALES BEFORE
DISTRIBUTOR CAN PROFITABLY WORK
WITH THEM. WE ALWAYS SAY THAT
DTC IS THE DISTRIBUTION ON RAMP
FOR SMALL DISTILLERIES ENABLING
US TO GROW TO A POINT WHERE WE
CAN BE SUCCESSFUL IN THE THREE
TIER SYSTEM. OVER THE PAST
TWENTY ONE MONTHS THANKFULLY DUE
TO THE A. B. C.'S EMERGENCY
ORDER CALIFORNIA'S DEALERS HAVE
BEEN ALLOWED AND HAVE PROVED
THAT WE CAN SAFELY SHIP SPIRIT
USING COMMON CARRIERS LIKE UPS.
REQUIRING SIGNATURE VERIFICATION
JUST LIKE THE WINERIES TO. DOING
SO THE STATE HELP SAVE OUR SMALL
BUSINESS INCLUDING INCLUDING MY
OWN. INCREASED JOBS WHILE
PROVIDING SAFE AVENUES FOR
CONSUMERS TO RECEIVE THE
PRODUCTS THEY WANT. THE
SENTENCING DTC DIRECT CONSUMER
AS AN ISSUE WHERE SOMEONE LOSES
WE SHOULD LOOK AT THE WINE
INDUSTRY TO SEE THAT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS CAN BENEFIT. THE
WHOLESALERS AND RETAILERS
BENEFIT A STUDY DONE BY CHIP
COMPLIANT WAY MENTIONED EARLIER
SHOWED THAT. BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND ELEVEN AND TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THE WINE
INDUSTRY'S SALES GREW FROM
THIRTY ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS TO FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS. OF THIS SALES INCREASE
CLOSE 260% STILL WENT THROUGH
THE TRADITIONAL WHOLESALE AND
RETAIL CHANNELS SO WHOLESALERS
AND RETAILERS IN A TEN YEAR
PERIOD GAINED OVER FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES. THE LABOR
BENEFITS DTC ALLOWS DISTILLERS
TO GROW BY SHIPPING PRODUCT VIA
CARRIERS LIKE UPS FEDEX AND
CONSUMERS ARTIFACTS TO
CONSUMERS. AS A RESULT
DISTILLERIES BRO HIRING NEW
EMPLOYEES THEY CAN BUY TANKS AND
BARRELS AND GLASS AND COURSE
MATERIALS WHICH ALL GET
DELIVERED VIA TRUCKING INDUSTRY.
IF DTC DOESN'T GO THROUGH GROWTH
OF DISTILLERS STAYS SLOW WHICH
WILL KEEP LABOR STAGNANT. AND
ULTIMATELY THE CONSUMER BATON
BENEFIT. THE CONSUMER BENEFITS
BY PROVIDING THEM WITH THE
SAFETY AND CHOICE CONSUMERS ARE
BUSY IN DEMAND THE ABILITY TO
PURCHASE SPIRITS FROM THE
CONVENIENCE OF THEIR COMPUTER
JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER PURCHASE
THEY MAKE. GOOD WINE AT DINNER
GROCERIES CLOTHING WHATEVER YOU
CAN IMAGINE THESE DAYS. THE
CONSUMER DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE IN SHIPPING LAWS
BETWEEN WINE AND SPIRITS THEY
SEE BOTH AS PART OF THE SAME
CALIFORNIA CRAFT ALCOHOL
INDUSTRY. BY PURCHASING DIRECTLY
FROM THE PRODUCER OF THE
CONSUMER GETS QUALITY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND A SENSE OF
SUPPORTING A CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS. HOW CALIFORNIA CAN
BENEFIT. WELL SPIRITS EXCISE
TAXES THREE DOLLARS AND THIRTY
CENTS A GALLON SIXTEEN AND A
HALF TIMES HIGHER THAN THE
TWENTY CENTS PER GALLON OF WINE.
A MERE 25% OF THE VOLUME OF THE
WINERIES IT COULD RE REPRESENTED
DITION OF HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW EXCISE TAXES. ON TOP OF
THE JOBS TOURISM SALES AND
EXCISE TAXES NEW PRODUCTION
FACILITIES WILL GENERATE NEW
REAL ESTATE TAXES THAT WILL IN
TURN BENEFIT LOCAL COMMUNITIES
SCHOOL FIRE AND POLICE. A WIN
FOR THE STATE AND FOR THE
COMMUNITIES. IN CONCLUSION SINCE
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA DISTILLERS HAVE BEEN
SAFELY SHIPPING DIRECT TO
CONSUMER AND EVERYONE HAS BEEN
BENEFITING. WE NEED DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING TO BE MADE
PERMANENT. SO CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN GROW AND THRIVE.
AS THE WINE INDUSTRY HAS
DEMONSTRATED OVER THE PAST
THIRTY FIVE YEARS. I ASK YOU TO
FOLLOW THE ROAD MAP OF THE WINE
INDUSTRY HAS ALREADY PROVIDED
AND SUPPORT PERMANENT DTC
SHIPPING. THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
TIME IN YOUR CONSIDERATION IN
THIS MATTER I I'LL BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ACTORS PANELS
OVER. VERY MUCH MISTER BILL
CONNOR. WILL NOW MOVE TO MISTER
DAVID OSCO WOULD DISCUSS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'M DAVID US GO FROM THE
DISTILLED SPIRITS COUNCIL OF THE
UNITED STATES MORE COMMONLY
KNOWN AS DISCUSSED. WE ARE THE
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE LEADING
PRODUCERS AND MARKETERS OF
DISTILLED SPIRITS SOLD IN THE U.
S. DISCUS HAS BEEN WORKING IN
CONCERT WITH THE AMERICAN CRAFT
DISTILLERS ASSOCIATION THE
AMERICAN DISTILLING INSTITUTE
AND THE CALIFORNIA ARTISANAL
DISTILLERS GUILD ON DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING TOMORROW WROTE
EQUAL TREATMENT FOR DISTILLED
SPIRITS. WITH THE DISTILLED
SPIRITS INDUSTRY AND ENSURE THAT
SPIRITS MAY ENJOY THE SAME
RIGHTS THE WINE INDUSTRY HAS
ENJOYED FOR DECADES. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ORGANIZING THIS THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON DIRECT
TO CONSUMER SHIPPING FOR
CONSUMER SPIRITS CONSUMERS OR AS
WE HAVE BEEN CALLING IT
DISTILLERY TO DOORBELL. THIS
CASE IS PLEASED TO REPRESENT
DISTILLED SPIRITS MANUFACTURERS
WHILE THERE ARE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES ON THE APPROACH TO
THIS POLICY AMONG MANUFACTURERS
THERE IS STRONG SUPPORT FOR A
SET OF FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES TO
GUIDE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIPPING
LEGISLATION. AND STATES THAT
CHOOSE TO PURSUE EXPANDING
CONSUMER ACCESS TO DISTILLED
SPIRITS PRODUCTS SIMILAR TO THE
ACCESS CONSUMERS HAVE. MORE WINE
. THE MODERN DAY CONSUMERS WANT
ENHANCED CONVENIENCE WHEN IT
COMES TO PURCHASING THEIR THEIR
FAVORITE PRODUCTS INCLUDING
DISTILLED SPIRITS. WHETHER
PRODUCED IN STATE OUT OF STATE
OR OUT OF THE U. S. IN RECENT
YEARS THE WORLD OF COMMERCE HAS
CHANGED AND WILL CONTINUE TO
CHANGE DRAMATICALLY.
PARTICULARLY IN THE WAKE OF THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. OUT THE
PANDEMIC IT'S CERTAINLY ONE
REASON FOR CONSUMERS DEMANDING
MORE CONVENIENCE BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT CODE ONLY
ACCELERATED CHANGES WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING IN THE MARKET
PLACE. NOW I KNOW WE'RE ALL
HOPEFUL THAT THE WORST OF THE
PANDEMIC IS BEHIND US BUT
CONSUMERS NOW MORE THAN EVER OR
SHOPPING FOR PRODUCTS PRODUCTS
IN MANY CHANNELS AND WE ALL MUST
ADAPT TO MEET CONSUMER DEMAND.
DISCUSS RECENTLY RETAINED IWS
ARTICLE CONSUMERS ABOUT THEIR
INTEREST IN BEING ABLE TO HAVE
SPIRITS PRODUCTS SHIPPED TO THEM
WHITE WINE. SO WHAT THE SURVEY
SHOWED IS THAT NATIONALLY 73% OF
ALL HOUSEHOLDS. NATIONWIDE
SHOPPED ONLINE FOR GROCERIES AND
47% REPORT THAT THEY ARE
SHOPPING ONLINE MORE FREQUENTLY
THAN LAST YEAR. 80% OF CONSUMERS
SURVEYED BELIEVE DISTILLERS
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO SHIP
DIRECTLY SHIP THEIR PRODUCTS TO
LEGAL AGE CONSUMERS IN ANY STATE
. AT LEAST 76% OF CALIFORNIANS
AGREED THAT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO ORDER SPIRITS DIRECTLY FROM
DISTILLERS AND THAT DISTILLERS
SHOULD HAVE THE SAME PRIVILEGES
AS WINERIES TO DIRECTION. WHILE
CONSUMERS DESIRE FOR ENHANCED
CONVENIENCE IS SUPPORTED BY THE
USE OF THIRD PARTY E. COMMERCE
WEBSITES. THERE ARE FOR EXAMPLE
THE SPOKE PRODUCTS AND THOSE
MADE BY CRAFT DISTILLERS IN
INCLUDING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT PART AVAILABLE THROUGH
THESE PLATFORMS. WE BELIEVE THAT
ALLOWING DISTILLERIES TO SHIP
DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS JUST AS
THE WINE INDUSTRY IS PERMITTED
IN FORTY SEVEN STATES COULD HELP
MEET THIS GROWING CONSUMER
DEMAND. CURRENTLY ELEVEN STATES
INCLUDING THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA ALLOW DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING OF SPIRITS IN
SOME FORM OR FASHION AND FIVE
OTHER STATES INCLUDING CAROL
CALIFORNIA ARE TEMPORARILY
ALLOWING LIMITED INSTATE
SHIPPING DURING THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC- SOME
DISTILLERS THE ABILITY TO SHIP
THEIR SPIRITS RODUCTS DIRECTLY
TO THEIR CONSUMERS BECAME A
CRITICAL LIFELINE. WHILE THEIR
DISTILLERY TASTING ROOM HOURS
AND TOURS WERE CURTAILED DURING
THE PANDEMIC. MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS ALSO UTILIZE NEW AND
EXISTING MODELS TO DELIVER
SPIRITS FROM RETAILERS THROUGH
THE THREE TIER SYSTEM INCLUDING
THE USE OF THIRD PARTY E.
COMMERCE WEBSITES THAT ALLOW
CONSUMERS TO PURCHASE. ONLINE
AND HAVE IT DELIVERED TO THEIR
DOORSTEP RESPONSIBLY. THOSE
MODELS WHICH ARE UTILIZED BY
WINE PRODUCTS PRODUCERS AS WELL
OPERATE WITHIN THE STATE'S
EXISTING REGULATORY THREE TIER
STRUCTURE AND ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DISCUS CONTINUE TO SUPPORT SUCH
MODELS. THESE KEY COMMERCE
MODELS HAVE PROVIDED NEW
CONVENIENT ACCESS FOR CONSUMERS
WHEN A PRODUCT IS AVAILABLE
THROUGH AN ACCESSIBLE RETAILER.
DISTILLERY TO DOORBELL
LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE FURTHER
CONSUMER CONVENIENCE BY ENABLING
CONSUMERS TO ORDER A BESPOKE OR
LIMITED RELEASE PRODUCTS THAT
ARE NOT AVAILABLE THROUGH LOCAL.
RETAILERS LAST IN ADDITION TO
PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT TO
CALIFORNIA CRAFT DISTILLERS
FACING FINANCIAL HARDSHIP DUE TO
THE NINETEEN BUSINESS
DISRUPTIONS DISRUPTIONS.
ADOPTING DISTILLERY THE DOORBELL
LEGISLATION TO PERMANENTLY ALLOW
DISTILLERIES TO SHIP. TO
CONSUMERS CREATES A MORE
CONVENIENT MARKET PLACE IN
RESPONSE TO CONSUMERS DEMAND.
FOR INCREASED CHOICE AND VARIETY
. DISCUS STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
THREE TIER SYSTEM AND WE BELIEVE
THAT DISTILLERY THE DOORBELL
LEGISLATION WILL BE A GREAT
COMPLEMENT TO TRADITIONAL
DISTRIBUTION CHANNELS. AS WE'VE
SEEN IN THE WINE INDUSTRY THE
VAST MAJORITY OF SALES WILL
CONTINUE TO FLOW THROUGH ALL
THREE TIERS BUT DIRECT TO
CONSUMER LEGISLATION WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CONSUMER
CONVENIENCE AND ACCESS TO
PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOT AVAILABLE
IN THEIR LOCAL MARKET. IN THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS THE NUMBER OF
DISTILLERIES HAS INCREASED FROM
AROUND SEVENTY TO MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND NATIONWIDE.
INCREASINGLY CONSUMERS WANT TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE NEW AND
EXCITING SPIRITS PRODUCTS THAT
OFTEN MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE IN
THEIR STATE. CERTAINLY EXPANDING
DISTILLERS ABILITY TO DIRECTIONS
SPIRITS TO CONSUMERS WILL ALSO
INTRODUCE MORE CONSUMERS TO
CALIFORNIA CRAFT DISTILLER
BRANDS AND PRODUCTS. CONSUMERS
WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO OBTAIN
LIMITED RELEASE PRODUCTS AND
CLUB OFFERINGS OR TO SHIP
PRODUCTS HOME DIRECTLY AFTER
VISITING A DISTILLERY. DISCUS
MEMBERS ARE FULLY COMMITTED TO
RESPONSIBLE CONSUMPTION AND
ENCOURAGE MODERATION FOR ADULTS
WHO CHOOSE TO DRINK ALCOHOL WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH
FORTY SEVEN OTHER STATES HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY AND SAFELY ALLOWED
WINE PRODUCTS TO SHIP WINE
PRODUCERS TO SHIP WINE TO
CONSUMERS IN THE STATES FOR
YEARS. THE PAST TWO YEARS HAVE
SHOWN US THE SPEED AT WHICH
MARKETS CAN CHANGE AND THE ROUTE
TO MARKET FOR DISTILLED SPIRITS
PRODUCTS CONTINUES TO MOVE ALL.
WE APPRECIATE THAT ANY
COMPREHENSIVE DIRECT TO CONSUMER
MODEL NEEDS TO ACCOUNT FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDER INTERESTS REGULATORS
DISTILLERS WHOLESALERS RETAILERS
AND CONSUMERS. AND WE CERTAINLY
THINK THAT THE CHAIRMAN AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR INCLUDING JUSTICE
TODAY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE INPUT AT THIS JUNCTURE.
ACCOUNTING FOR ALL STAKEHOLDER
VIEWS WILL HELP TO ENSURE THAT
THE LEGISLATION IS WELL THOUGHT
OUT AND AVOID ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. AND DURING
IMPLEMENTATION. SO TO ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR IN DEVELOPING SOUND
DIRECT CONSUMER SHIPPING-LEGISLATION DISCUSSES ADOPTED
SEVERAL PRINCIPLES THAT WE
BELIEVE WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
THE LONGSTANDING EFFECTIVE. AND
ROBUST REGULATORY SYSTEM FOR
BEVERAGE ALCHOL YEAH IF YOU'RE
IN CALIFORNIA. WILL CONTINUE TO
FIRST PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SECONDGUARD AGAINST UNDERAGE
SALES AND THIRD ENSURE THAT THE
STATE TAX COLLECTIONS- OR OR-
THAT THE STATE COLLECTS ALL
TAXES FOR SALES WITHIN THEIR
BORDERS. SO SOME OF OUR
PRINCIPLES INCLUDE THE FIRST
SUPPORT WE SUPPORT REASONABLE
SHIPPING LIMITATIONS ON DIRECT
TO CONSUMER PURCHASES. SECONDLY
WE WANT WOULD LIKE TO INSURE
THAT BROUGHT. THAT PRODUCT IN.
THREE TIER SYSTEM INTEGRITY- WE
INSURE THE FULL A BLACK HOLE AND
SALES TAXES TO THE STATE WHERE
THE PRODUCT IS DELIVERED.
REQUIRE EFFECTIVE SAFEGUARDS
AGAINST UNDERAGE PURCHASES AND
FINALLY REQUIRE ANY ALCOHOL
DIRECTORSHIP OR IN THE CARRIER
TO MAINTAIN DETAILED RECORDS SO
CERTAINLY HELP WITH- ANY SORT OF
AUDIT TRAIL. SO WHILE THESE ARE
JUST A FEW OF THE DISCUSS
PRINCIPLES WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
HAVE A MORE DETAILED
CONVERSATION REGARDING THE
POLICY CONSIDERATIONS-
CONSIDERING THESE PRINCIPLES. IN
CLOSING IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
WORLD OF COMMERCE IS CHANGED AND
MARKETS MUST ADAPT TO MEET
CONSUMER DEMAND WHEREVER THEY
ARE SHOPPING AND LOOKING FOR NEW
PRODUCTS. YOU WILL NO DOUBT HEAR
SCARE TACTICS ABOUT THE PRACTICE
OF DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIPPING.
OPPONENTS OF ALLOWING DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING- SPIRITS TO
CONSUMERS WILL RELATE STORIES OF
INADEQUATE TAX COLLECTIONS IN
VIRGINIA ON WINE SHIPMENTS WHICH
WERE SUBSEQUENTLY AND VERY
PROUDLY RESOLVED BY THE VIRGINIA
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
AUTHORITY. THEY ALSO CITE
INSTANCES OF LAWSUITS FILED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF MICHIGAN
AGAINST RETAILERS. GET IT THAT'S
RETAILERS NOT SUPPLIERS
ILLEGALLY DELIVERING WINE TO
CONSUMERS IN THE STATE THE KEY
WORD HERE BEING ILLEGAL. WE URGE
YOU TO FOCUS ON THE FACTS AND TO
ASK POINTED QUESTIONS WE URGE
YOU NOT TO LET FALSE OR BASELESS
CLAIMS DISSUADE YOU FROM
CONSIDERATION OF APPROPRIATE
RESPONSIBLE. AND BALANCED
LEGISLATION. AND SOME WE ASK
THAT YOU GO ALONG BEYOND THE
HEADLINE CONSIDER THE FULL STORY
BEHIND THE SENSATIONALIZE
ASSERTIONS. ALL THAT SAID WITH
THE PROPER SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE
AFTER HAVING ASKED THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS. ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE INDUSTRY WE BELIEVE THERE IS
NO PUBLIC POLICY REASON WHY THE
SPIRITS INDUSTRY SHOULD BE
PRECLUDED FROM MARKET MARKET
ACCESS CHANNELS THAT HAVE BEEN
ENJOYED BY WINE PRODUCERS AND
THEIR CUSTOMERS. AROUND THE
COUNTRY FOR DECADES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. MR OSCAR- WE'RE GONNA
BE ASKING QUESTIONS AFTER MANY
SPOKEN BUT I WOULD LIKE-
MISTRUST GO TO FOR YOU TO GET
YOUR GUIDING PRINCIPLES TO OUR-
CHIEF CONSULTANT SO THIS. COULD
BE HANDED OUT TO OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ARE NEVER GONNA MOVE TO
MISTER ERIC GREGORY PRESIDENT
THE KENTUCKY DISTILLERS
ASSOCIATION MISTER GREGORY. YOU
CAN BEGIN. WELL THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN DIED- SENATOR ALLEN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI MY NAME IS
ERIC GREGORY AND I'M PRESIDENT
OF THE KENTUCKY DISTILLERS
ASSOCIATION. WE'RE A NONPROFIT
TRADE GROUP THAT WAS FOUNDED
ACTUALLY WAY BACK IN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY. WE REPRESENT SIXTY FIVE
DISTILLERS FROM GLOBAL GIANTS
LIKEJIM BEAM KEVIN HILL OF
BROWN FORMAN. TO DOZENS OF SMALL
FAMILY OWNED CRAFT DISTILLERS
THAT ARE TRULY BUILDING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF OUR TIMELESS
CRAFT. KENTUCKY IS YOU KNOW IS
THE BIRTHPLACE OF BOURBON- WE
CRAFT 95% OF THE WORLD'S SUPPLY.
WITH A RICH HISTORY HERITAGE
DATES BACK MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
YEARS. AND LIKE CALIFORNIA WINE-
THOUGH NOT AS BIG KENTUCKY
BOURBON IS A SIGNATURE INDUSTRY
HERE AND A SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
AND TOURISM ENGINE FOR THE
STATE- WE GENERATE BY NINE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
OUTPUT EVERY YEAR EMPLOY ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND. OUR WORKING
KENTUCKY THIS END- GENERATE
ABOUT BILLION DOLLARS IN
PAYROLL. END OF FUN FACT THERE
ARE NOW TEN POINT THREE MILLION
BARRELS OF BOURBON CURRENTLY
AGING IN KENTUCKY THAT'S A
RECORD. MEETING WE HAVE TWICE AS
MANY BARRELS OF BOURBON HERE
THAT WE HAVE ACTUALLY PEOPLE
LIVING IN THE COMMONWEALTH OF
KENTUCKY- NOW I COULD TALK ABOUT
ARBOR MIST YALI MOM BUT WE'RE
HERE TO ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT
THREAT CONSUMER SHIPPING WHICH
IS A RLATIVELY NEW ENDEAVOR.
FOR KENTUCKY BOURBON IN THE
SPIRITS INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE. BUT
FIRST LET ME EXPLAIN WE SAY
THANKS TO CALIFORNIA REALLY FOR
LEADING THE WAY. WHEN WE CREATED
THE KENTUCKY BOURBON TRAIL IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. WE SIMPLY
WERE TRYING TO REPLICATE THE
INTERNATIONAL SUCCESS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAD CREATED. BY
PAIRING WINE INTERESTS. AND THE
SAME GOES FOR SPIRITS AND
SHIPPING. CALIFORNIA AS YOU
HEARD HAS BEEN RESPONSIBLY
SHIPPING IT'S ONE FOR DECADES
NOW. AND WE'RE SIMPLY FOLLOWING
THE INNOVATIVE PATH THAT YOU'VE
CHARTERED. AND CONTINUE MAKING
THAT CONNECTION WITH BOURBON
LOVERS AROUND THE WORLD. WELL
SPIRITS ARE NOWHERE NEAR THE
FORTY SEVEN STATES THAT
CURRENTLY ALLOW WIND DTC
SHIPMENTS. WE HAD TO START
SOMEWHERE AND FOR KENTUCKY THAT. POINT IN TIME WAS TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN. NOW ARE SOCIETY IS
CLEARLY BEEN MOVED TO. DELAY FOR
ALL SORTS OF ITEMS. DUE TO THE
GROWTH OF AMAZON ANOTHER
CONVENIENT SERVICES SO WE JUST A
MATTER OF TIME BEFORE THAT TRADE
REALLY CAME TO KENTUCKY WHERE
MORE THAN SEVENTY PERCENT. OF
OUR VISITORS TO THE KENTUCKY
BOURBON TRAIL ARE FROM OUTSIDE
THE STATE. THEREFORE THE NUMBER
ONE QUESTION FROM OUR VISITORS
IS WHY CAN'T I SHIP MY BOURBON
HOME. SO THE KENTUCKY
LEGISLATURE RESOLVED THAT
PROBLEM IN TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. BY ALLOWING IN PERSON
VISITORS TO DISTILLERIES TO SHIP
A LIMITED NUMBER BOTTLES HOME.
BUT WE QUICKLY LEARNED THAT ONLY
A HANDFUL OF STATES ALLOWED
SPIRITS SHIPMENTS. WHICH
RESTRICTED OUR EFFORTS AND
FRUSTRATED CONSUMERS. THE NEXT
YEAR OUR FRIENDS AT THE WINE
INSTITUTE ASKED KENTUCKY
LAWMAKERS TO FINALLY OPEN OUR
BORDERS TO WHINE IN SHIPMENTS.
AND FULL ECOMMERCE WITHOUT THAT
IN PERSON SALES. THIS ESCALATED
DISCUSSIONS AND NEGOTIATIONS
OVER DIRECT CONSUMER SHIPPING
FOR NOT ONLY WINE BUT BEER AND
SPIRITS. AND LEAD TO A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW- IN OUR
LEGISLATURE INVOLVING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS SEGMENTS OF THE
THREE TIER SYSTEM JUST AS YOU'RE
HAVING HERE TODAY. A BILL
ALLOWING FULL DTC WAS FILED IN
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY AND ONLY
PASSED BY THE KENTUCKY GENERAL
ASSEMBLY A YEAR LATER. JUST AS
YOU KNOW CONSUMERS RAMPED UP
THEIR DEMAND FOR ALCOHOL
SHIPPING AND DELIVERY AS THE
PANDEMIC CLOSE RESTAURANTS BARS
AND FORCE PEOPLE TO QUARANTINE
AT HOME. YOU CAN CHECK THE
LATEST UPDATED THE NEW ALL THIS
YEAR TO ALLOW FOR FILMING
CENTERS UPON THE REQUEST AGAIN
FROM THE WINE INSTITUTE. AND A
LARGE WINERIES THAT USE THEM TO
EFFICIENTLY PROCESS SHIPMENTS.
AND I SHOULD POINT OUT HERE THAT
WE ENCOURAGE OUR WHOLESALE
PARTNERS TO BECOME THE FILM
CENTERS FOR DTC SHIPPING- IN
KENTUCKY SINCE THEY ALREADY HAVE
OUR PRODUCTS. BUT THEY DID THE
CLIENT AND INSTEAD THEY THEY DID
OPPOSE THE BILL. SO I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO KIND OF QUICKLY EXPLAIN
HOW KENTUCKY'S DID YOU SEE WHAT
WORKS. AND IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO
THE BILL THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU. OUR DISTILLERS ALLOWED TO
SHIP ONE CASE OF SPIRITS PER
CONSUMER PER MONTH. WHILE
WINERIES IN BEER CAN SPEECHES
TEN CASES PER CONSUMER PER
MONTH. BOTH IN STATE AND OUT OF
STATE MANUFACTURERS MUST SUBMIT
THEIR HOME STATES LICENSE IN
ORDER TO GET A KENTUCKY SHIPPERS
LICENSE. WHICH ONLY COST A
HUNDRED DOLLARS. THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO COLLECT AND REMIT
ALL TAXES MONTHLY AND THEN SEND
A REPORT OF ALL SHIPPING
TRANSACTIONS QUARTERLY. TO OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT OF REVENUE
INTERSTATE EIGHTY C. ALL
MANUFACTURERS MUST KEEP DETAILED
SHIPPING RECORDS FOR AT LEAST
FOUR YEARS. AND MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE FOR AUDIT INSPECTION
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF REVENUE AND
THE ABC UPON REQUEST. COMMA
CARRIERS LIKE ABC CAN ONLY SHIP
FOR MANUFACTURERS TO HAVE THIS
DIRECT APPROACH LIGHTS. THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO UPDATE THAT LIST OF
LICENSEES EVERY QUARTER AND STOP
SHIPPING FOR ANY MANUFACTURER
THAT DOES NOT MAINTAIN THEIR
LICENSE. AND LIKE YOUR BILL EACH
SHIPMENT MUST BE CLEARLY LABEL
CONTAINS ALCOHOL SIGNATURE OF
PERSON AGE TWENTY ONE OR OLDER
REQUIRED FOR DELIVERY. AND OUR
LAW ALSO REQUIRES DISTILLERS
INCOMING CARRIERS TO CHECK A
GOVERNMENT ISSUED ID SUCH AS A
LIGHT DRIVER'S LICENSE UPON
DELIVERY. SO HOW WAS THE T. C.
WORKING IN KENTUCKY. WELL THE
KENTUCKY ABC TODAY HAS ISSUED
SIX HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN DIRECT
STRIPPERS LICENSES SIX HUNDRED
SEVEN THOSE ARE FROM OUT OF
STATE MANUFACTURERS OF WHICH 75%
ARE FROM CALIFORNIA. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT EIGHTY NINE
KENTUCKY DISTILLERIES WINERIES
AND BREWERIES THAT HAVE OBTAINED
DIRECTION FIRST LICENSE. A LOT
OF OUR KENTUCKY DISTILLERS ARE
SHIPPING AGAIN STATE AND THE
TARGETED AREAS LIKE WASHINGTON
DC AS THEY LEARN HOW TO LEGALLY
RESPONSIBLY NAVIGATE THE DTC
PROCESS EITHER BY THEMSELVES OR
THROUGH THE THIRD PARTY
COMPIANCE SYSTEMS LIKE YOU
HEARD SHIP COMPLIANT POOR
SPIRITS THREE SIXTY. ARE BIGGER
DISTILLERS HAVE RELIED ON CLUBS
WITH SPECIALLY BOTTLES LIKE
MAKER'S MARK WHICH S CREATED
UNIQUE VARIATIONS OF ITS MAKER'S%
MARK FORTY SIX BRAND USING THEIR
WOOD FINISHING SERIES THAT HAS
BEEN VERY POPULAR WITH CONSUMERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THANK SOME
DISTILLERS QUITE FRANKLY-
WAITING FOR MORE STATES TO PASS
DTC LAWS HOPEFULLY LIKE
CALIFORNIA BEFORE REALLY
INVESTING IN THE STAFF IN THE
PROCESS OF THE SHIP. ANY CRAP
TO. OBVIOUSLY ARE USING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO MARKET THEIR
BRANDS ESPECIALLY SINCE SOME
SAILORS. DO NOT KERRY EVERY
EXPRESSION THE DISTILLERY MAKES
. NOW S. MY FRIEND DAVID ALSO
SAID YOU'RE YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM OPPONENTS ABOUT A LOSS OF
TAX REVENUE IN PROBLEMS WITH
RESPONSIBILITY. I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING IN KENTUCKY
I CHECKED IN YESTERDAY WITH OUR
A. B. C. AND THE PARTNER
REVENUE. AND THE DEPARTMENT
REVIEW REPORTED THAT SHIPPERS
ARE PAYING THEIR TAXES AND
THEY'RE NOT AWARE OF ANY
COMPLIANCE ISSUES AND THE SAME
THING GOES FOR A. B. C. THEY
SAID THEY HAVE NOT SEEN ANY
PROBLEMS OR COMPLAINTS WITH TTC
IN KENTUCKY. FINALLY LET ME WRAP
UP AND SAY. THAT THE KDHE IN OUR
MEMBERS DO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PREACHER SYSTEM. BUT WE ALSO
SUPPORT MEETING CONSUMERS
DEMANDS. AND THAT'S WHERE THE
DTC COMES INTO PLAY AS A
COMPLEMENT TO THE EXISTING
PRINTER SYSTEM. WE DON'T WE'VE
SEEN AND HEARD ALL THE SCARE
TACTICS DURING KENTUCKY. FROM
OPPONENTS SOON JUST DON'T WANT
TO CHANGE. AND AS WE POINTED OUT
CALIFORNIA'S INCREDIBLE WINE
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN SHIPPING FOR
DECADES. WITH BARELY A PEEP OF
OPPOSITION AND THE REALITY IS
THE THREE TIER SYSTEM IS ALIVE
AND WELL ACROSS THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. OUR DISTILLERS LIKE
YOU'RE FINE WINERIES TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY SERIOUSLY. OUR
LICENSES AS THE DIMENSIONS ARE
ON THE LINE. WE PARTNER KENTUCKY
WAS STATE OF THE ART STATE OF
THE ART DEVELOPERS LIKE
INTELLICHECK. TO CHECK ID'S AND
WE MIGHT SPONSOR SAFE RIDE
PROGRAMS WITH LEFT ON MAJOR
HOLIDAYS. THAT TAKE POTENTIAL
DRUNK DRIVERS OFF THE ROADS. IN
FACT OUR KENTUCKY D. C. LAW IS
MUCH STRONGER ON ANY CHECKS. ON
LICENSED RETAIL DISTILL DELIVERY
SERVICES THAT ARE NOT REQUIRED
BY STATUTE YOU CAN TAKE A CHECK
ID'S UPON DELIVERY. AND THEY'RE
EVEN ALLOWED TO USE UNDER A
DRIVER TO PERSONALLY. DELIVER
BOTTLES WITH LITTLE OR NO
OVERSIGHT. SO WHEN YOU HEAR THE
SUBSTANTIALLY CONCERNS ABOUT
THINGS LIKE CONSOLIDATION OF THE
STORE MANUFACTURERS. WHICH IS
ALSO UNTRUE- YOU KNOW REMEMBER
THERE ARE NOW OVER TWO THOUSAND
DISTILLERS AND ALL FIFTY STATES.
THEY'RE CREATING GOOD PAYING
JOBS LOCAL BRANDS AND INVESTING
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. WE'RE
GONNA HEAR ARGUMENTS ABOUT
COMING HERE IS NEEDING MORE
REPORTING. WHICH ALL THAT REALLY
DOES IS CREATE AN UNNECESSARY
BUREAUCRATIC RED TAPE AN
ARTIFICIAL BARRIER TO DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING. THE KENTUCKY
LAW PUTS THE RESPONSIBILITY
REPORTING ON THOSE WHO KNOW WHAT
IS BEING SHIPPED AND WHERE IT'S
BEING SHIPPED. WHICH IS THE
MANUFACTURER. AND WHEN IT COMES
TO TAXES. YOU KNOW OUR OPPONENTS
ARE STATING THAT THE STORY
SOMEONE USUAL BREAK THE LAW. AND
WILL REMIT TAXES THAT ARE OWED
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE FOLLOWING THE
SAME INTERSTATE PROCESS THAT
AMAZON AND OTHER OUTLETS DUE TO
COLLECT AND PAY TAXES. WE'VE
ALSO HEARD ALLEGATIONS THAT
WE'RE GONNA SHIP COUNTERFEIT
PARK BROUGHT UP COUNTERFEIT
PRODUCTS. IN ROOM TWO HUNDRED
YEARS OF CREDIBILITY AND
GOODWILL. YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT'S
QUITE FRANKLY OFFENSIVE TO US-
BOTTLE PRODUCED BY DISTILLER
WHICH IS BOTTLED AND SEALED AND
THEN DELIVERED DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMER. IS JUST AS SAFE AND
HOW IT'S HANDLED TODAY. THE
TRUTH IS THERE ARE LAWS ON THE
BOOKS TO CATCH STOP LOSS AND
CHRIS WE ALSO SUPPORT STRICTER
ENFORCEMENT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
OPPONENTS ARGUE THAT'S GONNA
COST MORE BUT IT'S PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO COST AS MUCH AS THE
INCREASED BROCK PROCEED TO
REVIEW BIRDS SOME COMIC EUROPEAN
WORK THAT THEY OFTEN RECOMMEND.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE FOR KENTUCKY
IS DTC HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
DECADES THANKS IN LARGE PART TO
YOUR ONE INDUSTRY. A CALIFORNIA
STANDS TO BENEFIT MORE THAN ANY
OTHER STATE. ACCORDING TO THE
TTB CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION
WITH NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
OPERATING PERMITS FOR DISTILLED
SPIRITS PRODUCERS ABOUT OURS.
THAT'S ALMOST FIVE TIMES AS MANY
AS WE HAVE HERE IN KENTUCKY AND
WE'VE BEEN DISTILLING FOR OVER
TWO HUNDRED YEARS. WITH THE
GROWTH AMERICAN SPIRITS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY CONSUMERS ARE
DEMANDING ACCESS TO PIONEERING
NEW CRAFT BRANDS AS WELL AS
INNOVATIVE EXPERIMENTAL AND
PERSONAL SELECTIONS FROM LARGER
DISTILLERS. SO AS THE CALIFORNIA
ONE HISTORY HAS PROVEN
SUCCESSFULLY TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. ALCOHOL CAN BE SHIPPED
RESPONSIBLY AND EFFECTIVELY WITH
ALL TAXES PAID IN THE THREE TIER
SYSTEM IT'S A LOT OF WELL. SO
THANK YOU FROM KENTUCKY AND I'LL
BE GLAD WHEN THE COUNCIL TO
ENTRY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER GREGORY- AS A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE- I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- GO ON A FIELD
TRIP AND VISIT THE BOURBON TRAIL
I WOULD RECOMMEND THAT- TO
ANYBODY AND I THINK THAT YOU
INDICATED IN YOUR TESTIMONY
THAT- YOU'RE TRYING TO REPLICATE
WHAT WAS GOING ON IN THE
CALIFORNIA. WINE INDUSTRY AND I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT- IMITATION IS
THE HIGHEST FORM OF FLATTERY AND
YOU'VE GOT A HELL OF A GOOD JOB
BUT I REALLY ENJOYED IT VERY
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. SO AT THIS
POINT IN TIME I'M GONNA CALL ON
NATALIE SOLAR SO- CHILLERS-
SKEWS ME THAT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION- MISSED CHILDREN
CHILLER WHOSE- SORRY FOR **** UP
YOUR NAME YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IT'S MY USBAND'S
FAULT SO GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- AS SENATOR DODD
SAID- MY NAME IS NATALIE
CHILLERS- AND I'M THE CO OWNER
OF RUSSIAN RIVER BREWING COMPANY
IN SANTA ROSA AND WINDSOR
CALIFORNIA. IN CINEMA COUNTY-
WHERE WE HAVE TO BREW PUBS WE
SELF DISTRIBUTE WITHIN A ONE
HUNDRED MILE RADIUS OF ARMORIES
WE PARTNER WITH SIXTY THIRD
PARTY WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTORS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE
THREE OUT OF STATE ARMORIES BEEN
IN BUSINESS SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN AND WE OPENED OUR
FIRST BREWPUB IN DOWNTOWN SANTA
ROSA IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR I ALSO
RECENTLY SERVED NINE YEARS ON
THE CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION'S BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. TWO OF THOSE AS BOARD
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TODAY TO
SHOW MY SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BEER INDUSTRY
IS ALREADY EXISTING PRIVILEGE
ALLOWING BEER MANUFACTURERS TO
SHIP DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
UNLIKE DISTILLED SPIRITS THIS IS
A PRIVILEGE THAT BOTH REASON
WINERIES HAVE ENJOYED IN
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES TODAY I
AM REPRESENTING ALL CRAFT
BREWERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA TO
IMPRESS UPON YOU THE IMPORTANCE
OF SHORING UP THIS EXISTING
PRIVILEGE. THROUGH LEGISLATION
TO HARMONIZE OUR STATE STATUTES
WITH FEDERAL. LAWS HERE'S OUR
STORY. IN EARLY MARCH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. 51% OF OUR
TOTAL COMPANY REVENUE WAS
GENERATED THROUGH OUR TOO BUSY
BREWPUBS IN CINEMA COUNTY FALL
49% CAME FROM WHOLESALE SALES TO
BARS RESTAURANTS AND STORES
THROUGH SELF DISTRIBUTION AND
OUR WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTOR
PARTNERS HAVE ARE DISTRIBUTED
BEERS RESULTING K. EGGS TO BARS
AND RESTAURANTS. ON MARCH
NINETEENTH GOVERNOR NEWSOM LIKE
SO MANY OTHER GOVERNORS AND
HEADS OF STATE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND BEYOND ISSUED A
MANDATORY STATE HOME ORDER AND
SHUT DOWN ALL GROUP PUBS VERY
TAPROOMS WINERY AND DISTILLERY
TASTING ROOMS RESTAURANTS AND
BARS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
SUDDENLY BOTH OF OUR BREWPUBS
WENT DARK AND WE WERE FORCED TO
FURLOUGH ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO EMPLOYEES EVERY BAR AND
RESTAURANT TO HIM WE AND OUR
WHOLESALERS DELIVERED BEER WERE
GONE IN AN INSTANT AND EVERY
TANK OF BOTH PARISE WAS
COMPLETELY FULL. AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE PENICK SAID AND
IMMEDIATELY HOW ARE WE GOING TO
MAKE OUR MASSIVE LOAN PAYMENTS
WHAT WE HAVE TO DUMP ALL OF THAT
BEER DOWN THE DRAIN WE'RE GOING
TO LOSE EVERYTHING WE HAVE
WORKED SO HARD TO BUILD. BUT IF
WE ARE GOING TO LOSE IT ALL WE
WEREN'T GOING DOWN WITHOUT A
FIGHT MY HUSBAND DANNY SUGGESTED
WE STARTED SELLING MORE BEER
ONLINE DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHICH WAS SOMETHING
WE HAD DONE ON A LIMITED BASIS
SINCE WE OPENED OUR FIRST
PROPOSED EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO WE
HAD ABOUT EIGHTEEN HUNDRED CASES
OF OUR FLAGSHIP DOUBLE IPA PLINY
THE ELDER AND DOG A BLIND PIG
IPA THE REMARKS ARE NOW CLOSED
GROUP HUBS ALTHOUGH WE ONLY HAD
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SHIPPING
BOXES ON HAND NO LABEL PRINTERS
AND ABSOLUTELY ZERO EXPERIENCE
SELLING HIGH VOLUMES OF ANYTHING
ONLINE. I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE A
GREAT IDEA TO MAKE ALL EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED CASES AVAILABLE IN OUR
ONLINE STORE I WASN'T COMPLETELY
SOLD ON THE IDEA BUT AGREED ONCE
YOU CONVINCE ME THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO BUY MORE SHIPPING BOXES
IF NEEDED. SO I ADDED BOTH YOUR
STORE ONLINE STORE MADE A POST
ON SOCIAL MEDIA WE SAT THERE.
AND WATCHED ORDER START
TRICKLING IN. THEN THEY WERE
ROLLING IN ST ONE HUNDRED CASES
WERE SOLD DOWN TO. CASE BY THE
TIME WE WENT TO BUY THAT NIGHT
WE WERE OUT TO ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED. I WAS GETTING WORRIED
ABOUT NOT HAVING ENOUGH SHIPPING
BOXES AND SEE JUST TO PULL IT
DOWN. REALLY CONVINCED ME NOT
REALLY. THAT HE WOULD HAVE NO
PROBLEM FINDING MORE BOXES SO I
WISH HIM GOOD LUCK AND WENT TO
BED. THE NEXT MORNING TO REMOVE
BOTH BEERS FROM OUR ONLINE STORE
AFTER SELLING MORE THAN FIFTEEN
HUNDRED CASES. OF COURSE WE
SPENT THE NEXT WEEK SCRAMBLING
TO FIND AS MANY SHIPPING BOXES
BECAUSE- SO HAVING THE ABILITY
TO IMMEDIATELY CHANGE OUR
BUSINESS MODEL IN A MATTER OF
DAYS TO INCLUDE. DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING OF BEER
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT LITERALLY SAVED US
DURING KIND OF IT WAS THE
LIFELINE WE NEEDED TO HELP
FINANCIALLY GET THROUGH THE MOST
DIFFICULT AND DARKEST OF TIMES.
DIRECT TO CONSUMER ALSO SAVED
HUNDREDS OF SMALL WORRIES FROM
GOING OUT OF BUSINESS DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHEN THEIR TAPROOMS AND
BREWPUBS WERE COMPLETELY SHUT
DOWN. THOUSANDS OF SMALL
BREWERIES AROUND THE COUNTRY
RELY PRIMARILY ON WHAT'S CALLED
ON PREMISE SALES. FOR THEIR
TAPROOMS BREWPUBS AND ONLINE. IT
ALSO GAVE US AND OTHER BREWERIES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE JOBS
FOR EMPLOYEES. WHO WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN LAID OFF. ANOTHER
BRIGHT SPOT IN OUR TOTAL SWITCH
TO DIRECT TO CONSUMER WERE ALL
VERY NICE COMMENTS AND MESSAGES
WE RECEIVE FROM CONSUMERS.
LETTING US KNOW HOW ORDERING OUR
BEER ONLINE WE'LL START GOING
HOME WITH SOMETHING THEY REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO. THAT BOX OF OUR
BEER SHOWING UP ON THEIR
DOORSTEP WAS. IN SOME SMALL BUT
MEANINGFUL WAY HELPING THEM GET
THROUGH COVERAGE. WE CONTINUE TO
SELL BOTTLES AND CANS ONLINE
WEEKLY THROUGHOUT TWENTY TWENTY.
INCLUDING OUR EVER POPULAR PLAN
FOR PRESIDENT A DOUBLE DRY
HOPPED DOUBLE IPA IN A CAN TO
COMMEMORATE THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION. I EVEN KNOW OF A FEW
STATE LEGISLATORS ABOUT. LINE
FOR PRESIDENT ONLINE TO. DIRECT
AGAINST WENT FOR LESS THAN
PERCENT OF OUR TIME OVER COME
REVENUE 12% BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY. WHILE WHOLESALE SALES TO
DISTRIBUTORS. INCREASED FROM 49%
TO FIFTY EIGHT PERCENT.
THANKFULLY LIMITED OPERATIONS IN
OUR GROUP PUBS ALSO ALLOWED US
TO MAINTAIN SOME ON SITE SALES.
YOU MIGHT BE ASKING RIGHT NOW
BUT WHAT ABOUT YOUR WHOLESALE
DISTRIBUTORS. DOESN'T DIRECT TO
CONSUMERS CUT INTO THEIR PROFITS
WITH CUSTOMERS HAVING THE
ABILITY TO ORDER DIRECTLY FROM
YOU. AND NOT HAVE TO GO TO THE
STORE. BY PASSING THE THREE TIER
SYSTEM ALL TOGETHER. ONE WOULD
THINK THIS TO BE THE CASE BUT
THE EXACT OPPOSITE IS TRUE. YOU
IN APRIL AND SEPTEMBER TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THE FIRST FULL
SIX MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC. WHEN
IT WOULD DRAMATICALLY AFFECTED
OUR BUSINESS OPERATIONS SALES
AND CHART CALIFORNIA WHOLESALE
DISTRIBUTORS ALONE. NOT
INCLUDING OUT OF STATE
WHOLESALERS OR SOMEHOW STOCKS
STOCK DISTRIBUTION. WERE UP 63%
OVER TWENTY NINETEEN AND KEEP IN
MIND THAT THIS WAS ALMOST
ENTIRELY BOTTLED BEER WHICH IS
MORE PROFITABLE. TO US AND
WHOLESALERS THEN KAY. NOW THAT
OUR BUSINESSES ARE MOSTLY RE
OPENED AND YOUR CONSUMERS HAVE
MORE OPTIONS FOR PLACES TO BUY
AND CONSUME CRAFT BEER. DIRECT
TO CONSUMER CONTINUES TO REMAIN
AN IMPORTANT AND VIABLE PART OF
OURS AND OTHER BREWERIES OVERALL
BUSINESS. THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO REACH NEW
CUSTOMERS IN AREAS WHERE WE ARE
NOT YET DISTRIBUTED. AND DIRECT
TO CONSUMERS A GREAT MARKETING
TOOL TO ATTRACT AND MAINTAIN
LOYAL CUSTOMERS. WERE THEN ABLE
TO BUY OUR BEER AND BARS STORES
AND RESTAURANTS. THUS HELPING TO
BUILD OUR BRANDS INCREASED
DEMAND FOR OUR PRODUCTS. DIRECT
TO CONSUMER IS ALSO A GREAT WAY
TO SELL BEERS ONLINE THAT ARE
NOT AVAILABLE AT ALL FOR
DISTRIBUTION. SUCH AS ALL OF OUR
CANNED BEERS AND SPECIALTY ONE
OFF SMALL BATCH BREWS. THE
FEEDBACK FROM CUSTOMERS HAS BEEN
OVERWHELMINGLY POSITIVE. NOW
THAT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PURCHASE ARE HARD TO FIND BEERS.
IT IS ALSO THE ONLY WAY WE ARE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN OUR BEER CLUBS
AND SUCH A GEOGRAPHICALLY LARGE
STATE. AND WAS. A SAFE WAY TO
DELIVER THOSE. I'M DURING THE
COUNTDOWN. THIS IS WORKING TO
PRINT THIS. PRIVILEGE FOR THE
INTRODUCTION TWO BILL. SB FIVE
ONE SEVEN REQUIRE AN SP SIX TWO
ZERO ALAN WHICH WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING. THESE BILLS WILL
HARMONIZE OUR STATE STATUTES
WITH EXISTING FEDERAL LAWS. THUS
AVOIDING DISRUPTION TO THIS VERY
IMPORTANT PRIVILEGE FOR
CALIFORNIA CACKERS. THANK YOU
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY. AND ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND THE REST OF THE PANEL
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MYSTERIES OF APPRECIATE YOUR-
PRESENTATION- WE HAVE QUESTIONS-
FREDDY THE PANEL MEMBERS. I'M
NOT. SURE RUBIO THANK YOU JUST A
CLARIFYING QUESTION- YOU KNOW I
REALLY AM. I'M JUST THANKFUL
THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO CONTINUE
N. DOT BE ABLE TO KEEP ALL THOSE
FOLKS EMPLOYED BECAUSE AT THE
EXEMPTION CAN SOMEONE HELP- LET
ME KNOW WHEN IS THE EXEMPTION.
CONCLUDED WHEN IS THIS GOING TO
TERMINATE. YEAH WITH THE NEW
YEAR YEAH. BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR IS THAT WHAT THE ANSWERS.
OKAY THAT'S IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR WELL VERSED THANK YOU MR
CHAIR- JUST MISTER VILLA CON AND
NOT A QUESTION A COMMENT YET IN
MY CABINET HOME IS YEAR CUCUMBER
VODKA WHICH IS REALLY QUITE
REFRESHING SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR PRODUCING THAT IT'S ONE
OF MY WIFE'S FAVORITES. IN TERMS
OF QUESTIONS- THE GOVERNMENT FOR
MISTER GREGORY HE TALKED ABOUT
HOW THERE'S TWO THOUSAND
DISTILLERIES ACROSS AMERICA A
MORNING IF THIS WENT INTO EFFECT
IT WILL IF THIS WOULD AFFECT
WHOLESALERS IN ANY WAY AND BEING-ABLE TO CARRY EVERY BRAND AND-
VARIETAL IN ANY GEOGRAPHIC
REGION THE UNITED STATES SAID IT
MIGHT BE A SPECIAL BOTTLE THAT
CONSUMERS ARE LOOKING FOR IS IT
WITH THERE WERE TO BE ANY.
IMPEDIMENT TO THAT. I'M I'M TO
TRYING TO FOLLOW YOUR QUESTION
SO IF. YOU'RE SAYING IF IT
OPENED UP TO ALL. TO PRECLUDE
ANY WHOLESALER FROM BEING ABLE
TO OFFER ANY PARTICULAR PRODUCT
NO. NOPE NOT NOT EVEN ON OUR
OPINION I MEAN ONE OF THE YOU
KNOW BUT AS WAS MENTIONED ABOUT
THE WINE INDUSTRY DO THE
CONSUMERS ARE LOOKING FOR- YOU
KNOW SPECIALTY BOTTLES- IN
DIFFERENT EXPRESSIONS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT- WHICH WE HAVE PLENTY
OF HERE IN KENTUCKY SO- THAT'S
NOT GONNA STOP US FROM YOU KNOW
PUTTING THOSE BOTTLES OUT TO
WHOLESALERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND RETAILERS EITHER. I GOT A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS FOR YOU I
MEANT TO ASK ANOTHER ONE FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE BUT THAT'S OKAY AS
THE GREAT GREAT GREAT GREAT
GREAT GREAT GRANDSON OF DANIEL
BOONE I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
SUPPORT TACKY I FOUND THAT OUT
LAST YEAR REALLY PRETTY
INTERESTING SO YOU MENTIONED
THAT THAT THAT THE BIG BOURBON
PRODUCERS HAVE HAVE- CLUB SO I'M
ASSUMING THAT LIKE WINE CLUBS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. RIGHT YES. I
DO THIS DO THE SMALLER. OFFER
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY AS WELL.
MANY OF THEM ARE YOU KNOW IT AND
AGAIN THIS IS SUCH AS AT AND
EARLY ENDEAVOR. INDUSTRY I'M
SORRY YEAH IT'S AN EARLY
INTEREST YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
EARLY JUST RESET MOST OF THEM
ARE SHIPPING YOU KNOW BOTTLES
THAT- THERE THE RETAILERS
TYPICALLY DON'T CARRY THE HOPES
ARE STILL KERRY WHERE IS THE
LARGEST STORIES- YOU KNOW
NOBODY'S GOING TO BUY A BOTTLE
OF REGULAR MAKERS MAC BY RICK
REGULAR BALLOT MAKER'S MARK AND
HAVING IT SHIPPED IN PAPER
SIPPING AWAY TWO WEEKS TO GET IT
WHEN THEY GO TO THEIR LOCAL
LIQUOR STORE GET IT. ENJOYED
IMMEDIATELY- SO THE BIGGEST
SOURCE FOR MOST OF LOOKING AT
CLUBS RIGHT NOW OKAY THAT WAS MY
NEXT QUESTION SO PEOPLE ARE NOT
BUYING SOMETHING THAT I COULD I
COULD GO TO THE LIQUOR STORE OR
COSCO OR WHATEVER THEY'RE
THEY'RE BUYING SPECIALTY BLENDS
CORRECT RIGHT RIGHT SO FAR YES.
AND AGAIN WE DON'T ANTICIPATE IT
HAVING AN EFFECT ON THE REGULAR
BRANDS YOU CAN GET IN JOY-
BECAUSE JUST FOR CONVENIENCE
PURPOSES AND FOR COST PURPOSES
WHY WOULD YOU- AGAIN GO PAY ME
TO PAY MORE AND WAIT. TO HAVE IT
SHIPPED WHEN YOU CAN GO TO YOUR
LOCAL PACKAGE STORE GET IT
IMMEDIATELY GREAT THANK. YOU SO
MUCH- THANK YOU. THE QUESTION MR
GRADY COMING YOUR WAY A COUPLE
OF MAYBE. IN YOUR EXPERIENCE TO
KENTUCKY DISTILLERS. SHIP MAINLY
TO CONSUMERS IN KENTUCKY. OR TO
OTHER STATES THAT ALLOW DTC I
JUST DIDN'T REALLY. GET I THINK
YOU COMMENT ON THAT BUT I DIDN'T
REALLY FALL. RIGHT NOW IT'S
MOSTLY CONSUMERS IN KENTUCKY IN
A FEW SELECT IN STATES WHERE
IT'S EASY TO SHIP BECAUSE AS MR
OSCAR MENTION THERE'S ONLY.
ELEVEN STATES INCLUDING DC THAT
ALLOW SOME FORM DTC SHIPPING SO-
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH I KNOW THE- THE RED TAPE
IN THE LICENSING EVERYTHING ELSE
ALL OF THOSE STATES- THAT- YOU
KNOW AND WE HOPE TO HAVE MORE-
SO RIGHT NOW A LOT OF WE'RE
DOING KENTUCKY ONLY JUST TO KIND
OF. WORK OUT THE BUGS. IN DC IN
ALASKA IN SOME OTHER PLACES LIKE
THAT BUT WE WOULD HOPE TO SHIP
MORE YOU KNOW IT'S MORE STATES
COME ONLINE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND THEN ALSO ARE THERE ANY
LIMITATIONS ON HOW MANY BOTTLES
EACH DISTILLER. KINSHIP IN
KENTUCKY. AND YOU SEE IF THERE
ARE DO YOU THINK THOSE
LIMITATIONS ARE WORKING FOR MOST
DISTILLERS. YES SO. THE SOURCING
A TECHIE YOU CAN SHIP. UP TO TEN
BOTTLES PER CUSTOMER PER MONTH-
AND THAT WOULD BE THE SAME
COMING INTO KENTUCKY- UNDER A
WALL- WINERIES AND BREWERIES CAN
SHIP UP TO TEN CASES. PER
CUSTOMER PER MONTH. AND SO FAR I
HAVEN'T HEARD ANY COMPLAINTS
FROM ANYBODY ABOUT THOSE LIMITS
. OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT IN
MISS CHILLAR SO- ARE ARE THERE
ANY CONCERNS THAT ALLOWING OUT
OF STATE BREWERS TO SHIP INTO
CALIFORNIA CAN HURT CROP GROWERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALL I
DON'T BELIEVE SO- IT'S VERY IT'S
PRETTY COST PROHIBITIVE TO SHIP
OUT OF STATE- YOU KNOW FOR US
FOR EXAMPLE WE DID START LOOKING
INTO SHIPPING TO THE STATE OF
NEVADA BECAUSE BECAUSE IT HAS
SOME- SOME. DIRECTION BEING LAWS
THAT ALLOW CALIFORNIA BURRIS TO
SHIP TO NEVADA ONCE WE STARTED
TO GO DOWN THAT RABBIT HOLE WE
REALIZE THAT IT WOULD BE REALLY
REALLY EXPENSIVE TO SHIP TO
NEVADA EVEN JUST YOUR RENO-
THERE'S ALSO SOME CRAZY STATE
LAWS THAT WOULD ONLY ALLOW US TO
SHIP LIKE EIGHT A HALF BOTTLES
PER PERSON SO GENERALLY IN ANY
SENSE FOR US TO DO IT- BUT YOU
DID IT DID END UP BEING PRETTY
EXPENSIVE LIKE FOR EXAMPLE I
THINK THERE'S SOME LEGISLATION
GOING IN HAWAII. RIGHT NOW- TO
ALLOW- DIRECTORSHIP TO CONSUMER
SHIPPING THERE AND WE HAVE
FRIENDS THAT LIVE ON QUIET AND
WHENEVER WE SEND THEM YOU KNOW
CASE OF BEER FOR SOMETHING- IT'S
LIKE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
SO I DON'T REALLY FORESEE. THAT
BEING- HUGE ISSUE JUST NUMBER
ONE IT'S COST PROHIBITIVE AND
NUMBER TWO- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
MADE GREAT BEER IN CALIFORNIA SO
I'M NOT I'M NOT TOO WORRIED
ABOUT THE COMPETITION WE ALSO
HAVE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE IN OUR
STATES WE HAVE QUITE A LARGE
BEER DRINKING POPULATION TO
ABSORB A LITTLE BIT MORE SO I'M
I'M NOT TOO WORRIED ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU MISTER VILLA CONDO
SAME QUESTION FOR YOU IN THE-
CRAFT DISTILLERS. FROM FROM THAT
STANDPOINT. YEAH I KNOW I WOULD
TO CONCUR. IN AND BE ON THE Y.
SIDE WE HAVE THE TO SHIP WINES-
SO BASICALLY I'M VIRTUALLY EVERY
STATE AND IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND IT DOES COME DOWN TO COST
AND YOU KNOW EACH STATE HAS
DIFFERENT SET OF REGULATIONS I'M
SOME REQUIRE BONDS- ANNUAL
LICENSES REPORTING. AND UNLESS
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE YOU KNOW
ENOUGH CUSTOMERS IN EACH STATE
YOU CAN MAKE THAT DECISION IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR ME TO I
SAW THAT BUT TO. GET A LICENSE
TO SELL IN THAT STATE AND A LOT
OF TIMES IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
UNLESS YOU HAVE A REALLY BIG
CUSTOMER BASE- I'M ASSUMING THE
SAME THING IS WHEN PEOPLE ARE
GONNA BE SHIPPING TO CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU KNOW FOR US. WE HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF WE HAVE THE
AGRITOURISM PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE
COMING HERE- THEY'RE GONNA BE
VISITING THE DISTILLERS.
VISITING BIRDS VISITING WINERIES
AND THEN THEY BASICALLY THEY
WANT TO BASICALLY GET IT WHEN
THEY GO BACK HOME AND SO IF
ANYTHING I THINK IT GIVES US THE
ADVANTAGE- TO BASICALLY OPEN UP
SHIPPING OUT GOING BOTH WAYS-
BECAUSE- FOR US. IT'LL GIVE THE
SMALL CRAFT DISTILLERS CROPPERS
I CRAFT WINERIES AND THEIR
ABILITY TO BASICALLY HAVE A MUCH
BIGGER MARKET- AND CALIFORNIA
AGRITOURISM. YOU KNOW IT'S
ALREADY ESTABLISHED AND SO I
THINK IT'S A IT'S A REAL
BENEFIT- I IT'S NOTHING THAT I
THINK IS A SMALL DISTILLER. I'M
AFRAID I THINK YOU KNOW IT LIKE
IN THE WIND IS STREET I YOU KNOW
THERE'S BRANDS OF ALL SIZES- AND
YOU KNOW. THAT THE SAYING IN
INDUSTRIES YOU KNOW THE RISING
TIDE RAISES ALL BOATS AND SO I
THINK THE SMALL DISTILLER AND
THAT THE LARGEST DEALER CAN ALL
WORK TOGETHER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND US SENATOR RUBIO- YEAH
. WITH BY REQUEST RATHER THAN A
CALL EARLIER TO I THINK I MR FOR
KENTUCKY- DISCUSS A BILL THAT
YOU HELPED I BELIEVE IN FEBRUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY KENTUCKY AND
YOU TALKED ABOUT LIKE THE
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW PROCESS AT
THREE TIERS DO YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION YOU CAN JUST FORWARD
TO WHAT THE COMMITTEE I'M SORRY
WE DON'T RECEIVE ANY INFORMATION
FOR THIS COMMITTEE BUT IF WE CAN
MAKE SURE WE GET THAT
INFORMATION SO WE CAN REVIEW
AND- AND JUST YOU KNOW EXPLORE A
LITTLE FURTHER I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY PERFECT- I WAS
GETTING S. SENATOR BOONE- I MEAN
SENATOR WILK- TO SEE IF HE
COULD- PIE BUT HE'S APPARENTLY
LEFT THE MEETING TEMPORARILY I
KNOW THAT HE HAD ANOTHER
APPOINTMENT- WE GOT TO BE A
LITTLE LIGHT HEARTED AROUND
HERE- BUT NOW I DID HAVE- AND.
EXCUSE ME A SECOND HERE. OKAY
MISTER OZ GO YOU'RE STILL WITH
US SIR I GUESS I AM ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR
ORGANIZATION IS MADE UP OF BOTH
BIG AND SMALL DISTILLERS DO YOU
THINK DIRECT TO CONSUMER
SHIPPING CAN BE GOOD FOR BOTH. I
CERTAINLY YOU HAVE SOME OF THE
LARGE TRADITIONAL DISTILLERS
THAT EVEN THOUGH MANY OF THEIR
BRANDS- PROBABLY WOULD NOT BE
SHIPPED DIRECT BECAUSE THE PRICE
POINT. THEY ALSO HAVE A LOT OF
LINE EXTENSIONS AND HIGHER END
BRANDS THAT- YOU KNOW WHEN WE
LOOK AT THOSE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY GOING DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING THEY AVERAGE
ABOUT FORTY FIVE DOLLARS PER
BOTTLE. THAT'S ABOUT TRIPLE THE
AVERAGE- RETAIL PURCHASE OF A
BOTTLE OF SPIRITS. SO THEY
CERTAINLY HAVE THOSE HIGHER END
BRANDS THAT THEY WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN SHIPPING- YOU KNOW
THEY CERTAINLY HAVE- SPECIALLY
BOTTLES BOTTLE SPECIAL BOTTLINGS
THAT THEY THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SHIP- AND THEN OF COURSE THE
CRAFT DISTILLERS DATE ALSO- YOU
KNOW THEY SIMPLY WANT MARKET
ACCESS- IN MANY CASES YOU KNOW.
YOU ASK MISTER GREGORY EARLIER-
IF THE PRODUCTS WOULD IF ANY
PRODUCTS SHIPPED DIRECT WOULD
NOT BE AVAILABLE TO- WHOLESALERS
ALSO PRACTICAL MATTER A LOT OF
SMALL CRAFT. DISTILLERS COMPLAIN
IF I HAVE A HARD TIME BEATING
GETTING A WHOLESALER- TO GET
THEIR PRODUCTS AND THEN EVEN IF
THEY CAN THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
THE WHOLESALER DOESN'T GET THEIR
PRODUCT. THEIR PRODUCTS TO THE
PROPER TIME AND ATTENTION. YEP
SO AS A RESULT THE LARGE. RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WELL I
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
SPEAKERS THAT- JOINED US FOR
THIS PARTICULAR ANEL VERY
INFORMATIVE- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
ATTENTION YOU PUT INTO THIS AT
THIS TIME WE MOVED OUT OF THE
LAST PANEL WILL BEGIN WITH HELLO
HEATHER KALLIO WITH THE WINE AND
SPIRITS WHOLESALERS. OF AMERICA. MISS KELLY ARE YOU HERE WITH
US. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I'M GOING TO JUST
SHARE. MY SCREEN REALLY QUICKLY
OUR PRESENTATION- THANK YOU
AGAIN- AS NOTED MY NAME IS
HEATHER KALLIO I'M THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF THE WINE AND SPIRITS
WHOLESALERS OF AMERICA- I AM
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON TO
DISCUSS THIS VERY COMPLEX ISSUE-
AND APPRECIATE THE TIME- GIVEN
TO US TO. ADD YOUR WALK THROUGH
THIS- WE WELCOME THAT
OPPORTUNITY- AND WE'D LIKE TO
DISCUSS HOW CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
MARKET PLACE IS SAFETY PERSON
COMPETITIVE- UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM WHOLESALERS IN THE STATE
PROVIDED MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
JOBS THE FEELING UNNECESSARY
ROLE AS A KEY COMPONENT. OF THE
SYSTEM. WHICH ENSURES EFFICIENT
TAX COLLECTION A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD FOR BUSINESSES OF ALL
SIZES AND ACCOUNTABLE BUSINESS
PRACTICES TO PREVENT UNDERAGE
ACCESS ANOTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUES. POLICY UNDER
CONSIDERATION TODAY WOULD CREATE
MORE REGULATORY BURDENS- UNDER
MY NOSE BALANCE. OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY BENEFITS AND
INCREASES- SPENDING FOR OUR
REGULATORS AND STATE. MOST
IMPORTANTLY- THAT THERE ARE
OTHER MARKETPLACE OPTIONS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO BUSINESSES INTO
CONSUMERS JUST AWESOME DISNEY-
WST WAY AND ARE ON LOCAL
WHOLESALER PARTNERS WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THE
pMEMBERS OF THE INDUSTRY I WANT
RESPECT. HUMAN NEEDS ARE SMARTER
REGULATIONS- CALIFORNIA
WHOLESALERS- HOW ARE BIRDS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES- THANK YOU
RESPONSIBILITY SERIOUSLY I AM AT
WORK WITH THEIR ART SUPPLIER IN
REGIONAL PARTNERS TO ACCOMPLISH
THESE GOALS I WE TOOK A LOT OF
PRIDE IN THE BRAND BUILDING AND
MARKETING THIS IS DONE TO BRING
SOME OF THESE WONDERFUL PRODUCTS
TO MARKET- AND THEN TO WORK WITH
OUR RETAIL PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYTHING IS SOLD OUT
RESPONSIBLY AND THERE'S MINE
ESTATE FOR REGULATORS WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT IN THIS INDUSTRY
CONSIDERING THAT ALCOHOL IS NOT
LIKE ANY OF THOSE OTHER PRODUCTS
THAT YOU WOULD FIND ON AMAZON
NOT. YOU KNOW THE PAPER IT'S NOT
SNEAKERS IT IS A NON TOXIC AND
WE DO TEND TO TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF
HAVING THESE STATE BASED SYSTEM-
WHERE YOU HAVE ACCESS TO SOME OF
THOSE BUSINESSES TO MAKE SURE
THEY. ARE IN COMPLIANCE- THE
JOBS THAT ARE SUPPORT. BY OUR-
YOU KNOW MASSIVE IMPACT
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY-
DISTRIBUTORS CONTRIBUTE TO
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. TO THE
OVERALL ECONOMIC IMPACT AND WE
PARTNER WITH- YOU KNOW UNION
UNION PARTNERS THE TEAMSTERS TO.
PROMOTE AND PROTECT YOU OVER TEN
THOUSAND. IN STATE JOBS THIS IS
A REALLY REALLY- YOU KNOW.
EVERYONE'S TALKING ABOUT NUMBERS
EARLIER. BUT I TEND TO THINK
THEY'RE IMPORTANT THEY'RE NOT
SCARY THESE ARE REAL NUMBERS
THESE ARE REAL BUSINESS SENSE-
THAT REAL JOBS ARE SUPPORTED.
THESE FAMILIES AREN'T BAD.
STABLE SALARIES- AND I THINK
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
SHOULD TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
WE NOW- AS WELL THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM WORKS IT IS STATE ITS
DIVERSE IN ITS COMPETITIVE AND
IT WORKS FOR ALL MEMBERS OF THE
- WHOLESALERS RETAILERS ALSO
HELPS A LOT OF SUPPLIERS-
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK THIS
AFTERNOON ABOUT THE EXPLOSIVE
GROWTH OF OUR- DISTILLERS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. THAT'S HAPPENED
WITHIN THE THREE TIER SYSTEM AND
THAT'S HAPPENED FOR. AVS BECAUSE
THESE ARE REGULATIONS ENSURE
THAT HERE'S A PREDICTABLE
MARKET PLACE WHERE YOU CAN GROW
UP DISCUSSED- THAT THEIR TRADE
PRACTICE REGULATIONS THAT ARE-
THAT ARE ENFORCED AND RESPECTED
SO THAT YOU KNOW YOU A LARGE
SUPPLIER CAN'T FORCE OUT OF
SMALLER SUPPLIER THE- SHELF
SPACE THANKS THANKS TO THAT
NATURE. ALL THAT DOES JUST
APPEAR WHEN YOU GET INTO THAT
DTC MARKET PLACE- IT BECOMES A
LOT HARDER TO ENFORCE THEM AND
HONESTLY IT'S NOT FEASIBLE FOR
AID YOUR NAVY STREET APARTMENT
IN A STATE THAT WAS BUILT TO
ENFORCE THE FINITE NUMBER STATE
LICENSEES. TO START HAVING TO
POLICE YOU KNOW FORTY NINE OTHER
STATES IN DC IS BUSINESSES ARE.
REALLY HARD TO MAKE THAT REACH-
BUT WE KNOW THAT IN CALIFORNIA
THE WAY THAT THINGS ARE
STRUCTURED THEY JUST WORK- AND
THAT IF THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT. I HAD TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION. I DIRECT TO
CONSUMER- YOU KNOW IF ABOUT IT
FROM A LOT OF DIFFERENT TODAY
AND I REALLY DO AGAIN WE DO
APPRECIATE THIS HONEST AND OPEN
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT THIS ISSUE
DOES GET SOME YOU KNOW SOME AIR
TIME SOME DISCUSSION- BUT
THERE'S A LOTTHAT GOES ON IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS THAT. AND IT
TENDS TO GET OVERSIMPLIFIED. THE
FACT IS IT'S NOT A VERY SIMPLE
ISSUE- THIS COUNTRY- IN EVERY
SINGLE STATE HAS HAD A YOU KNOW
THEIR STRUGGLES WITH ALCOHOL AS
THE PRODUCT HOW IT SHOULD BE
SOLD WHEN IT SHOULD BE SOLD.
WHAT CAN BE SOLD ARE YOU ALL
EVERY SINGLE QUESTION AND- AND
THOSE THOSE QUESTIONS ARE ABOUT
IT FOR A LONG TIME WE'VE SETTLED
ON A SYSTEM THAT DOES WORK.
OTHER THREE TIER SYSTEM IT HAS A
LOT OF BENEFITS FOR THE INDUSTRY
AND FOR CONSUMERS- SO. YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU SAY THAT YOU HAVE TO
KNOCK IT DOWN. FOUR YOU KNOW
WHAT WE HAVE TODAY IS NOT A VERY
HONEST. LOOK AT YOU KNOW AT WHAT
THE SITUATION REALLY YES. I DID
YOU SEE DOESN'T COEXIST WITH A
THREE TIER SYSTEM IT'S AN END
RUN AROUND. ALL I CANNOT SCARE
TACTICS BUT I WILL GET INTO SOME
OF THE DATA LATER. ON IT. THE
EXISTENCE OF DIRECT TO CONSUMER-
OUTSIDE OF THAT STATE REGULATORY
SYSTEM IT DOES DIRECTLY
UNDERMINE THE ADVOCACY AND
BENEFITS OF. OF EVERY. EVERYONE
WHO IS PARTICIPATING IN THAT
SYSTEM RIGHT ALL OF THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY BENEFITS THAT
YOU SEE- FROM THOSE IN ST
THAT'S- ALSO UNDERMINES A LOT OF
YOU KNOW LOCAL RETAILERS. NOT
JUST THE WHOLESALERS BUT ALSO
THE RETAILERS. IF A PRODUCT IS
COMING IN FROM OUT OF STATE ON
REGULATED. THERE IS NO WAY TO
ENFORCE THOSE PRICECONTROLS OR
ANYTHING ELSE AND PRODUCT
APPROVALS THAT THAT YOU KNOW IN
ANY STATE. YES SIR THESE ARE.
ISSUES IT ALSO DOES TAKE AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF RESOURCES TO
HELP POLICE EFFECTIVELY
REGULATE. RESOURCES THAT REALLY.
WEREN'T DEDICATED NOTHER WE
ISSUE YOU KNOW POLICE EDUCATION
OR. EFFECTIVE REGULATION OF.
STATE OWNED- BRING LICENSEE
ACROSS LICENSE AND- R. ONE THANK
YOU AT W. AUSTIN WAY ALL OF OUR
STATE TO SEIZE ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS WE ARE REALLY FOCUSED
ON SEEKING SOLUTIONS WE KNOW
THAT THE MARKETPLACE IS CHANGING
AND E-COMMERCE IS HERE AND WE'VE
GONE AHEAD IN THE RACE THAT WE
WANT TO BE PART OF THAT- BUT
DIRECT TO CONSUMER IS NOT THE
ONLY E. COMMERCE SOLUTION I
THINK IT'S REALLY REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION TO HAVE
HERE. WITH THIS PANEL- AND WE'LL
CONTINUE THAT. AS AS I GO ON-
BUT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AFFECTIVE STATE REGULATORY
SYSTEMS OR FOR ALL SALES OF
ALCOHOL- WE DO REJECT THE IDEA
THAT JUST ASSEMBLY OF EFFECTIVE
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT IS
NECESSARY FOR CONSUMER
CONVENIENCE AND WE DO SUPPORT
COMPLIANT CONVENIENT OPTIONS
LIKE LOCAL LICENSE RETAILER
DELIVERY INSTEAD OF INTERSTATE
SHIPPING. AGAIN WE DO THINK THAT
THE DATE I WHICH I WILL GET INTO
NOT AS A SCARE TACTIC BUT
BECAUSE THE DATA THAT USED TO
MATTER IN THIS ARGUMENT- I WILL
GET INTO THAT LATER WE HAVE TO
BE A THREE WAY ALL ALONG WITH
OUR STUDENT ASSOCIATION. HAS
ISSUED- MULTIPLE SETS OF
GUIDANCE ON STATE INSPECTED. I
COMPU COMMERCE SOLUTIONS SUCH AS
DELIVERY- WE ARE YOU KNOW WE SEE
A LOT OF SUCCESS WITH THAT
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND KNOW THAT
THAT IS REALLY WHAT IS BEST FOR.
YOUR CONSUMERS IN THE
MARKETPLACE OVERALL- AS FAR AS
INNOVATION ON THE WHOLESALE
CHEER TO- TO ANSWER YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE INCREASED NEEDS
WITH- A LOT OF THESE PRACTICE
DEALERS THAT ARE POPPING UP ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY. YOU KNOW THE
WHOLE SHELTER HAS INTEGRATED-
BUSINESS SUCH AS COLLECTIVE
EXPATS WHICH REACHES 50% OF THE
U. S. MARKET PLACE AND CARRIES
TEN THOUSAND PRODUCTS IN. THERE
AS IS DOWN THE ROAD STATE
DISTRIBUTION FOR ALL OUR LIVES
IT IS A MEMBER OF W. S. TO BE
WAYNE'S BASED IN CALIFORNIA AND
IT PROVIDES INNOVATIVE WHOLESALE
SOLUTIONS FOR THESE CRAFT BRANDS
THAT ARE LOOKING FOR WHOLESALE.
PARTNERS TO HELP THEM DISTRIBUTE
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY SO THERE
AREN'T THERE'S A LOT OF.
INNOVATION GOING ON IN THE
MARKET PLACE RIGHT NOW THIS
ISN'T YOUR BINARY CHOICE
BETWEEN. THE TWO THING YOU KNOW
ACCESS TO THE MARKET PLACE
THERE'S- A LOT THAT GOES ON-
THERE AS WELL. I W. S. TO BE WAY
HAS PARTNERED WITH MANY CRAFT
BRANDS AROUND THE COUNTRY WE-
REALLY PUT A LOT OF RESOURCES
AND TIME INTO LESSENING BECOMING
BETTER PARTNERS FOR ALL OF OUR
CRAFT BRICK BRANDS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY- YOU KNOW TO SAY
OKAY YOU KNOW. ATC HAS PERCEIVED
INSIST ON THE SOLUTION WE KNOW
THAT THE LONG TERM IMPACT OF
THIS IS. THAT WE SEE IN OTHER
STATES FROM. FRONT LINE WHICH IS
NOT ALL SUNSHINE AND RAINBOWS.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN THAT THERE ARE
YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME SERIOUS
ISSUES. YOU KNOW HOW DEPENDENT.
WE HELP THESE BRANDS. I DO WE
LESSEN BETTER HOW DO I CLOSE THE
- I SO WE HAVE A- SUCCESSFUL
UNDERTAKE AND- AT. IT WILL BE
ROLLING WE HAVE LOT W. W. A.
ACCESS- WHICH DOES CONNECT SOME
OF THOSE BRANDS. THESE WITH
WHOLESALERS- AND AGAIN IT'S OUR
WAY OF BEING A BETTER LISTENER
WE KNOW. THAT A THREE TIER
SYSTEM HAS BENEFITS THAT ARE
WORTH. PROTECTING THAT RE WORTH
FIGHTING FOR BETTER OR WORSE
KEEPING IN THIS INDUSTRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE. THE US MARKET
PLACE IT IS. IS THE MODEL THAT
IT ISN'T A WORLD. SO WE KNOW
IT'S INCUMBENT ON OUR- THAT. TO
OFFER MORE SOLUTIONS- AGAIN BACK
IN ABOUT A WEEK OUR NEW OUR ROLE
OUR NEW AXIS PLAYBOOK WILL ROLL
OUT AND AGAIN THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT. OUR OUR ANSWER
TO A LOT OF THESE QUESTIONS. ARE
BY THE NUMBERS. ALL OF THIS
WHICH YOU KNOW AGAIN NOT SCARE
TACTICS- BUT JUST- NOW EIGHTEEN
STATES THIS YEAR THAT CONSIDER
DTCS. SHIPPING MEASURES- THERE
ARE FIVE STATES IN DC RIGHT NOW
THAT ALLOWS SHIPPING AND THE
NUMBER IS SO LOW BECAUSE A LOT
OF THESE STATES HAVE TAKEN A
LOOK AT WHAT THE ONLINE
MARKETPLACE REALLY YES. THERE
ARE SOME ISSUES NOW THERE'S A
LOT OF. YOU KNOW HOW WE DISCUSS
THESE THINGS WITH MY MYSTERY WE
KNOW THAT THEY ARE YOU KNOW
ENCOURAGE ALL OF THEIR MEMBERS
TO BE COMPLIANT AND THEY DO A
GREAT JOB AT THAT HOWEVER THERE
ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT ACTORS IN
THE EAST IN THE SHIPPING MARKET
PLACE. AND THERE'S  LOT OF
QUESTIONS A LOT OF EXTRA WORK A
LOT O PROBLEMS ON A TRACKING
DOWN CRIMINAL ELEMENTS. THAT THE
IS STATE REGULATORS NEED TO DO
ONCE DTC IS OPENED UP SO YOU SEE
THAT. EVERY STATE RIGHT NOW THAT
CONSIDERS. MEASURES THIS YEAR
DID NOT MOVE FORWARD- AGAIN IF
IT DOES ALSO HAVE LAID OUT ON
THE NATIONAL AGENT A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT NATIONAL POLICY GROUPS
WHERE AGAIN- THAT DATA WAS
CONSIDERED AND PRESENTED AND
WHAT WAS UNDERSTOOD IS THAT
ENFORCEMENT MEASURES ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT MEASURES. FOR STATE
REGULATORS SHOULD BE PURSUED TO
GET A BETTER IDEA OF WHAT GOES
ON IN THE WIND SHIPPING
MARKETPLACE AS OUT OF STATE
COMPANIES ALL SUPPLIERS AND
RETAILERS SHIPPING AND THIS
COLUMN. YES COULD I ASK YOU TO
CALL WE'VE GOT- FOUR SPEAKERS IN
THIS THING AND SO CAN I WE WANT
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
A COPY OF THIS DEBT BECAUSE I
FOUND A LOT OF- SO VERY
INTERESTING AND NEW INFORMATION
TO ME SO. I WOULD LIKE TO GET A
DEATH BUT IF YOU COULD KIND OF.
GET THROUGH THIS I WOULD
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE JUST SO- WE
CAN LET THE OTHER SPEAKERS
SPEAK. ABSOLUTELY AND I DO WANT
TO GET MY COLLEAGUES TIME SO I
WILL SAY YOU THERE WAS MENTION
OF. THIS TO SHARE SOME OF THIS
DATA IT'S NOT SCARE TACTICS THAT
IN ACTUAL REPORTS FROM
REGULATORS THROUGH THEIR
LEGISLATURES FROM KANSAS FROM
VIRGINIA OR MANY OTHER STATES.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT TO
YOU WE ALSO HAVE COPIES OF THESE
THINGS ON WSU ACTC KNOW THE
WHOLE STORY WEBSITE- THERE'S A
TON OF RESOURCES THEY'RE- BACK.
AGAIN HAPPY TO GUIDE YOU THROUGH
THAT BUT AGAIN BY THE NUMBERS
RIGHT NOW- WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA REVENUE
CALIFORNIA- MARKETPLACE REALLY
BENEFITS FROM VERY SOLID. STATE
REGULATIONS- SO ANY MOVE
BRINKLEY'S DTC OUR FIRST. WORLD
YOU GREASE REVENUE SINCE DAY AND
ALL OF MY MONEY IT WAS VERY
VALUABLE I OPE HI TEAM MOBILE
JOBS- OVERWHELMING EXISTING
REGULATORY SYSTEM AND INCREASE
THE REGULAR UNREGULATED
MARKETPLACE. I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AFTER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
MISS KELLY- NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO OUR NEXT WITNESS IS DAVID
KRIEGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA BEER
AND BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS. MR
KRIEGER WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS STEPHEN
HERE TODAY. CALIFORNIA BEER AND
BEVERAGE DISTRICT. ARE TRADERS
THAT'S- RIGHT. AND OF BEER
BEVERAGES. HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF DIRECT TO CONSUMER SIPPING A
BEER AND MALT BEVERAGES FROM OUT
OF STATE. ACTORS I DO NOT HAVE A
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
LICENSED PREMISES WITHIN THE
STATE. THE B. B. B. ACCORDING.
THREE TIER SYSTEM OF REGULATED
ALCOHOL DISTRIBUTION CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS THE REGULATORY
DISTRIBUTION REQUIREMENTS OF
LICENSING AND DELIVERY OF. THE
CURRENT SYSTEM HAS WORKED WELL
TO MAINTAIN A SAFE AND ORDERLY
MARKETPLACE C. B. D.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES EXPANSION
OF DIRECT TO CONSUMER SIPPING A
BEER FROM PRODUCERS IMPORTERS
WHOLESALERS AND RETAILERS FROM
ACROSS STATE LINES. EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW PERMITS BEER
MANUFACTURERS WITHIN STATE GROUP
BREWERY LICENSE ID EIGHTY EIGHT
SHIFTER PRODUCTS DIRECTLY TO
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS AND
CONSUMERS. EXPANDING DIRECTION
FROM OUT OF STATE ACTIONS UNDER
NOT UNDERMINE THE STATE'S
RECORDING REGULATORY INTERESTS.
IN MAINTAINING A SAFE MARKET
PLACE AND COULD LEAD TO SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
CORRECTION A BEER AND MALT
BEVERAGES ACROSS STATE LINES AND
DIRECTLY INTO THE HANDS OF
CONSUMERS INCREASED UNDERAGE
ACCESS TO REGISTERED TO A LACK
OF STATE REGULATORY OVERSIGHT.
BACKSTAGE SHIPPERS EVEN WELL
INTENTIONED ONES OFTEN HAVE
MINIMAL TIES TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND HAVE LESS
ABILITY AN ECCENTRIC HELP KEEP
OUR CALL AND ANSWER CHANTS. THE
KNITTING SYSTEM WORKS WELL TO
ENSURE THAT A LOCALLY PRESENT
RESPONSIBLE AND STATE LICENSE
ACTUALLY COMPLIES WITH
CALIFORNIA LAW INCLUDING AGE
VERIFICATION REQUIREMENTS WHILE
MAINTAINING A LONG TERM
INTEGRITY IN OVERSIGHT. OF STATE
LICENSED. AND REGULATED BEER
DISTRIBUTION HELP. INTERSTATE
DIRECT OF BEER INTO QUESTIONS
WHY. AND QUALITY CONTROL SUPPLY
CHAIN. IT RAISES ISSUES OF
CONCERN SUCH AS THE POTENTIAL
SHIPMENT OF EXPIRED- OR
ADULTERATED PRODUCTS. ASHLEY
CONCERNING THE- ARTICLE HAS A
LIMITED SHELF LIFE AND OFTEN
REQUIRES REFRIGERATION TO
MAINTAIN PRODUCT QUALITY.
QUALITY DEGRADATION IS DAMAGING
TO THE OVERALL BEER CATEGORY.
THAT'S RIGHT THE QUESTION WHO
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE. REGULATORS
WOULD HAVE LIMITED AUTHORITY TO
IMPOSE AND ENFORCE PENALTIES ON
OUT OF STATE CHAIRPERSON ALCOHOL
PRODUCTS ARE RECEIVED BY MINOR
OR WHEN ADULTERY OR EXPIRED
BEVERAGES ARE SHIPPED INTO THE
STATE. IT'S AN ONGOING INDUSTRY
ISSUE IN THE INDUSTRY IN FACT
RECENTLY- TELLING YOUR DRESS
CONCERNS OVER EXPIRED BEVERAGES
BOSTON BEER. THE PRODUCER OF
TRULY MORE BASED ON SEARCH AND
DESTROY- IT'S OVER PRODUCTION OF
RESULTS ARE BECAUSE IT WAS NEAR
EXPIRATION. IT WAS THE ENGINE NO
LONGER MEET STANDARD OF
COMMERCIAL QUALITY. CORRECT THE
CONSUMER SHIPMENTS MAY ALSO
RESULT IN BEER AND OTHER MALTED
BEVERAGES BEING SENT INTO THE
STATE WITHOUT PAYING FOR THE
REQUIRED HELPING EXTEND AXONS.
STATE LOCAL TAXES OR THE
APPROPRIATE STATE REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT. PRACTICING ALREADY
CHALLENGING TASK. ALLOWING OUT
OF STATE YOUR MANUFACTURERS TO
DIRECTLY SHOULD BE HELPING
CONSUMERS MAKE TAX RETURNS A
COLLECTION EVEN MORE DIFFICULTY
TENUOUS. AND CONCORD CALIFORNIA
BREWERS AT A DISADVANTAGE. IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE PROBLEMS ARE MOST
AFFECTED DEALT WITH TWENTY
EXISTING CREATURES SYSTEM I'LL
CALL DISTRIBUTIONS MAINTAIN.
BASED ON THESE ISSUES WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE POTENTIAL
EXPANSION OF DIRECT TO CONSUMER
SIPPING A BEER AND OTHER MALTED
BEVERAGES FROM OUT OF STATE.
ACTORS ON THE CALL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR KRIEGER NOW WILL MOVE TO
A MISTER MARLAND MANSUR-
PRESIDENT THE NEIGHBORHOOD
MARKET ASSOCIATION OF SAN DIEGO-
THANK YOU MR MONTOUR- PLEASE BE
BEGIN. THANK YOU AS WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING. IN
ALLOWING US ALL THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VOICE OUR CONCERNS WITH S. E.
SIX TWENTY. MY NAME IS MARLIN
SORT AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD MARKET ASSOCIATION
. WHICH IS A NONPROFIT TRADE
ORGANIZATION CONSISTING OF OVER
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY INDEPENDENT
RETAILERS. IN FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA THE
VAST MAJORITY OF WHICH SELL THE
BEVERAGES BEING DISCUSSED IN
INVOLVED WITH S. P. SIX ONE. WE
HAVE MANY CONCERNS WITH THE
POTENTIAL ENACTMENT OF THIS BILL
. IT WOULD HAVE ONE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES. THE
IMPACT ON FAMILIES IN THE
COMMUNITY. CALIFORNIA JOBS IN
THE TREMENDOUS ISSUES OF
CREATING A REGULATORY SCHEME. TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE NOW FIRST IN
REGARDS TO THE IMPACTS THIS LAW
WOULD HAVE A FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA FAMILY BEST
. EVERY SALE BY AN ODYSSEY
DISTILLER. WOULD BE ONE TAKEN
AWAY FROM A CALIFORNIA REACH.
THESE ARE RETAILERS WHOSE SALES
ARE VITAL TAX REVENUE FOR OUR
GOVERNMENT. IN TURN THIS EFFECTS
OF THIS NEGATIVE IMPACTS WOULD
HAVE ON SMALL FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES AND LOCAL BUSINESS
OWNERS WHAT FLOW DOWN AND REALLY
AFFECTS CALIFORNIANS FROM
GETTING QUALITY JOCKS AT THESE
MARKETS. SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND RETAILERS. HAVE BECOME A
PART OF THE FABRIC OF THE
COMMUNITY. THEY'RE NOT ONLY JOB
CREATORS ENGINE DRIVERS FOR OUR
ECONOMY. ESPECIALLY AS WE SEEN
IN THE LAST TWENTY PLUS MONTHS
ESPECIALLY IN TIMES WHERE IT'S
MOST NEEDED. OUR MEMBERS ARE
ACTIVELY IN LOCAL CHARITY
ORGANIZATIONS RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY AND
SOCIAL ORGANIZATIONS THEY'RE
PART OF THE FABRIC OF OUR GREAT
STATE. WHAT THIS LAW DOES IS
HURT SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS. WHO ALSO
REPRESENT THE EASIEST AND MOST
SIMPLE TRACK ON INSURING
COMPLIANCE UNDER REACH ACCESS TO
ALCOHOL SOMETHING THEY DO ON A
DAILY BASIS. IN REGARDS TO THIS
COMMITMENT TO COMPLIANCE IN
THESE ISSUES WITHOUT OF STATE
COMPLIANCE. OUR ORGANIZATION THE
NEIGHBOR MARCUS DECISION. LIKE
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES AND
RETAILERS HAVE A GREAT
CONNECTION AND OUTREACH WITH OUR
OUR STATE ABC. WE TEAM UP WITH
THE RECEIPTS ORGANIZED MASSIVELY
TRAININGS WITH OUR MEMBERS TO
ENSURE THEY ARE UP TO DATE WITH
NEW LAWS AND REGULATIONS AND
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH. ALL THE
LOSS JUST IN THE PAST COUPLE
WEEKS WE'VE HOSTED THE ABC
SUPERVISING AGENT IN CHARGE
LOCALLY DOWN HERE IN SAN DIEGO.
WHAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE JUST A
ONE HOUR MEETING ENDED UP
SURPASSING AN HOUR AND A HALF.
OUR BOARD MEMBERS AND MEMBERS.
WERE ASKING QUESTIONS WANTING TO
KNOW WHAT WAS NEW. WHAT IS THE
ABC CONCERNED WITH WHAT ARE
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO AS
RETAILERS TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE.
AND ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IS
BENEFITING FROM WHAT HAPPENS.
WE'RE IN CONSTANT CONTACT WITH
ABC LEADERSHIP YOU SEE GENERAL
COUNSEL SPOKE EARLIER TODAY.
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE ALWAYS IN CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION CONTACTS. THAT
BENEFITS OUR MEMBERS IN BENEFITS
B. B. C. AS WELL. LET'S GET A
BIT OF BACKGROUND ON ME JUST
THREE MONTHS AGO I WAS WORKING
AS A PROSECUTOR HANDLING DRUG
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
CASES MINORS IN POSSESSION.
SALES TO MINORS. CASES IN THIS
ROCK. WHY WOULD YOUR
ORGANIZATION WHOSE. BIG FOCUS
HAS THE SALE OF ALCOHOL LIQUOR
BEER AND WINE WHY WOULD THEY
HAVE SOMEONE LET ME RUN THIS
ORGANIZATION. THE ANSWER IS
SIMPLE. SCIENCE IS PARAMOUNT TO
SMALL BUSINESSES IT IS THEY'RE
LIKELY. IT AFFECTS THEIR
STANDING IN THE COMMUNITY. IF A
LOCAL RETAILER IS FOUND TO HAVE
SOLD TO A MINOR AND THAT WE'RE
GETS AROUND TOWN. THAT HURTS AND
DAMAGES THEIR REPUTATION MAKING
IT. IT IS VITAL THE FINES AND
SUSPENSIONS FOR VIOLATING. IT IN
A. B. C. REGULATION OR ANY OF
OUR LOSS. GREATLY IMPACTS OUR
RETAILERS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN PUT FOOD
ON THE TABLE. NOW I SEE
DISTRIBUTORS AND CONGLOMERATES
ARE NOT GOING TO DO THAT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE. A CONNECTION
WITH THEIR STATE ABC THEY'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE A COMMITMENT TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE ON A DAILY
BASIS. HOW TO USE FOR THEM TO BE
A DROP IN THE BUCKET AND ONE NOT
SUCCESSFULLY DID SURE. DID TURN
THESE LARGE CORPORATIONS FROM
ENSURING COMPLIANCE. READ AN
AVALANCHE OF ISSUES WITH
UNDERAGE ACCESS TO ALCOHOL. IT
pWOULD CAUSE THIS COMMITTEE AND
OTHER COMMITTEES. TALK TO FOCUS
ON CREATING A REGULATORY SCHEME
. IN INSIDE IN SHORT COMPLAINTS
FROM THESE OUT OF STATE
DISTILLERS. IN SOME OUR FOCUS IS
TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA FAMILY
OWNED BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIANS
SIX FEET ABOVE ALL ELSE I URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO THINK OF THE
TREMENDOUS. NEGATIVE IMPACTS
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE ON A FAMILY
OWNED BUSINESS. ON LOCAL
TAXPAYERS ARE EMPLOYEES THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
BE HERE WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR- MONSOOR- NOW WE HAVE-
MR BACK- PLEASE- MR BACK IS- THE
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE FOR
TEAMSTERS LOCAL EIGHT FIFTY
THREE WELCOME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMING TO OUR HEARING
TODAY VIRTUALLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS STEVE BACK AND I'M A
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE FOR
TEAMSTERS LOCAL EIGHT FIFTY
THREE LOCATED IN OAKLAND. I'M
HERE TODAY TO GIVE SOME INSIGHT
ON WHY SB SIX TWENTY BY SENATOR
ALAN IS NOT IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE WORKING CLASS
PEOPLE. NOT ONLY IN MY BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE WINE AND
SPIRITS INDUSTRY I'VE ALSO SPENT
TWENTY THREE YEARS OF MY LIFE
WORKING AS A SALES PERSON IN SAN
FRANCISCO. WHAT IS BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY NOT ONLY WILL
ALLOW LICENSED DISTILLERS TO GET
A FOOT IN THE DOOR TURNED OUT
THE FABRIC OF THE THREE TIER
SYSTEM. IT WILL DESTROY SEVERAL
THOUSANDS OF WELL PAYING UNION
JOBS AT ALL LEVELS FROM CUSTOMER
SERVICE SALESPEOPLE
MERCHANDISERS TELEMARKETING
SALES DRIVERS AND WAREHOUSE
PERSONS. THOUSANDS OF HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN WILL LOSE
GREAT MEDICAL BENEFITS HI
PENSION CONTRIBUTIONS.
RETIREMENT MEDICAL COVERAGE FOR
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES. AND
MANY OTHER NEGOTIATED BENEFITS.
OVER MANY YEARS WE HAVE BUILT A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LARGEST DISTRIBUTORS IN
CALIFORNIA. I KNOW SAME
DISTRIBUTORS HIRE HUNDREDS OF
UNION EMPLOYEES. IN ADDITION WE
HAVE ALSO PARTNER WITH THESE
SAME EMPLOYERS TO CREATE A SAFER
SALLY MARKET FREE FROM
VIOLATIONS OF A. B. C. AND D. T.
B. RULES LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
WE WORK TOGETHER ON COMPLIANCE
TRAINING FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES ARE
MEMBERS TO HELP EVERYONE
UNDERSTAND WHAT A LEGAL OR
ILLEGAL PRACTICE WOULD BE IN THE
INDUSTRY AND HOW TO STAY CLEAR
OF VIOLATIONS. DO WE REALLY
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS TAKING ALL
OF WHAT I'VE JUST STATED INTO
CONSIDERATION. I CAN'T HELP BUT
WONDER IF THIS WILL BE THE FOOT
IN THE DOOR THAT WILL ALLOW THE
LARGER DISTILLERS AND OTHERS TO
DISMANTLE THE THREE TIER SYSTEM.
AND THEN WHAT WILL BE WILL WE BE
COMPETING WITH AMAZON IF THEY
DECIDE TO START MANUFACTURING
SPIRITS. WE BE REPLACING GOOD
UNION JOBS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WITH LOW WAGE OPPORTUNITIES FROM
OUT OF STATE. WELL AS A SALES
PERSON AND A REPRESENTATIVE OF
SALES PEOPLE I APPRECIATE THE
NEED TO BRING A WIDE ARRAY OF
PRODUCTS TO THE MARKET. BUT WE
BELIEVE THIS CAN BE DONE SAFELY
AND EFFICIENTLY THROUGH THE
THREE TIER SYSTEM. A MODEL THAT
HAS BALANCED PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WITH EDUCATION TAXATION
AND THE CREATION OF JOBS AND
LISTENING TO SOME OF THE
STATEMENTS MADE HERE TODAY.
FINDS ME OF WHEN I WAS A SALES
PERSON A SAN FRANCISCO AND I WAS
WORKING WITH A SMALL CRAPS
DEALER ON TRYING TO INTRODUCE
PRODUCTS INTO SOME OF THE
ACCOUNTS AT SAN FRANCISCO. AND
IT REMINDS ME OF COMPLIANCE
WHERE THIS. SUPPLIER WAS
OFFERING FREE GOODS FOR EVERY
BOTTLE THAT WAS PURCHASED TO
THESE. TO THESE BUYERS AND
HALFWAY THROUGH THE DAY I HAVE
TO PULL TO THE SIDE AND EXPLAIN
TO HIM THAT THAT'S A VIOLATION
OF ABC LAW. YOU CANNOT DO THAT
AND HE HAD NO IDEA WHAT HE WAS
FROM OUT OF OUT OF STATE AND TWO
I REALLY DON'T BELIEVE IT REALLY
AFFECTED HIS DECISION ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER BECAUSE HE WENT ON FOR
THE REST OF THE DAY TO CONTINUE
TO OFFER THE FREE GOODS. AND
THAT IS JUST A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE THAT I'VE HAD-
WRITING WITH- ONE OF THE SMALL
CRAFT DISTILLERS. WITH THAT I'LL
GLADLY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ALONG WITH THE REST OF THE
PANELISTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SEVERAL. I'M I'M JUST
PLAIN FOLKS I'M I'M LETTING IT
RUN IN THE EFFORT TO GET ON A
PLANE SECOND YOUR DINNER MY
FAMILY BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY OF S. RELLY HELPS A
LOT OF THOUGHTS ABOUT SOME OF
THE THINGS HAVE BEEN SAID BUT I
WILL BE LISTENING TO THE
DISCUSSION AND THE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE ON THE FEET AS I.
HEAD TO THE AIRPORT TO THANK%
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU SENATOR.
YOU KNOW I'M JUST GOING TO KIND
OF GO THROUGH AND- AND- JUST
SELECTIVELY ASK SOME QUESTIONS
HERE- SO MISS MISS KELLY- IT IS
THERE SOME KIND OF LIMITATION ON
HOW MANY MANUFACTURERS CAN SHIP
- THAT YOU THINK YOUR
ORGANIZATION WOULD FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH. I MEAN IF IT'S
NOT EVERYBODY IS THERE. IS THERE
SOME NUMBER JUST TRYING TO- YOU
KNOW GET A REFERENCE ON THAT-
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT ONCE YOU
OPEN UP THE SYSTEM IT IT'S OPEN
RIGHT IT'S EITHER. DID YOU KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE REGULATORY
PROTECTIONS ARE EITHER THERE OR
IF THEY'RE NOT THERE SO- NO I
DON'T THINK THERE'S A NUMBER AT
THIS TIME THAT WE WOULD. BE
DISCUSSING- DEFINITELY A
DIFFERENT. SIDE A DIFFERENT. WAY
BUT NOT YOU INTERSTATE SHIPPING
RIGHT WHICH IS THE IMPORTANT
SIDE IF THAT'S COMING IN FROM
OUT OF STATE. SHE DID ANSWER AND
THEN I'M A FOLLOW UP WITH THAT.
ANOTHER QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT
HAS BEEN THE IMPACT OF WIND THE
WIND INDUSTRY HAVING THE
ABILITY. TO SHIP DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS. HAS THAT HURT
DISTRIBUTORS. I YOU KNOW
HONESTLY IT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
DISTRIBUTORS IT IS ABOUT THIS
INDUSTRY IS SO CLOSELY TIED
TOGETHER- IT IMPACTS EVERYONE
FROM YOU KNOW ALL THREE TIERS OF
THE BUSINESS TRUE. THE CONSUMER
HONESTLY- AND ESPECIALLY THE
STATE IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS SO
YOU KNOW. AGAIN I THINK THE
OTHER PANEL WAS TALKING A LOT
ABOUT SCARE TACTICS AND AGAIN I
DON'T I DON'T THINK THAT THEY
ARE SCARE TACTICS THEY ARE
ACTUALLY DATA. PROVIDED BY- THE
REGULATORY AGENCIES TO STATE AN
OFFICIAL REPORTS THE
LEGISLATURES THAT SHOW. IN THE
INSTANCE OF RIGID NIGH AND WENT
OVER 38% OF THE SHIPMENTS COMING
IN THAT COULD BE IDENTIFIED. ARE
ACTUALLY LEGAL IT DOESN'T MEAN-
BECAUSE- THERE WAS NO WAY FOR
THOSE BUSINESSES TO GET LICENSES
THAT THEY CHOSE NOT TO GET A
LICENSE AND CHOSE NOT TO BE
TAXES. EXCISE TAX INVOLVED GREAT
RETAIL TAX. AS YOU KNOW ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES JUST POINTED OUT
THEY WOULD NEVER MIND I GOT YOU
YOU IDIOTS ARE PRETTY MUCH THE
QUESTION I GUESS GOT TO GET
ENOUGH QUESTIONS OUT TO
EVERYBODY AND THEN WE HAVE.
PUBLIC COMMENTS SO SORRY TO CUT
YOU SHORT THERE I DID GET YOUR
POINT I AM LOOKING FOR TO GET
YOUR DESK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME- MR KRIEGER IN
YOUR OPINION HOW DIFFICULT IS
IT. FOR A BREWERY ENTER INTO A
DISTRIBUTION. CONTRACT WITH THE
DISTRIBUTOR. WHERE ARE SURE I-
QUALIFIED TO TALK THE- DETAILS
ON ON HOW DOES THE START BUT
WHAT I WOULD SAY IT'S BACK. WHEN
THINGS ARE REALLY PROUD OF- IS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN THE PATHWAY-
TO. THE DIVERSITY THAT YOU FIND
ON SHELVES OR YOU WALK INTO A
GROCERY STORE. AND YOU SEE THE
LARGE ARRAY OF CRAFT BEERS IN
FRONT OF YOU THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
A BIG REASON FOR THAT IS BECAUSE
OF THE THREE TIER SYSTEM AND THE
INVOLVEMENT OF OUR DISTRIBUTORS
ABOUT PROCESS OKAY. WELL I'VE
NOT BEEN PERSONALLY INVOLVED IN.
IN YOU KNOW THAT THE CREATION OF
THOSE ROADS BUSINESS OUR
ARRANGEMENTS- I CAN TELL YOU
THAT HISTORICALLY WE REALLY HAVE
LED TO THAT. ACCESS AND
AVAILABILITY- WHICH I THINK AT
THE END OF THE DAY IS ULTIMATELY
ONE OF THE GOALS RIGHT IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT CONSUMERS HAVE
CHOICE. YEAH I'M GONNA ASK YOU
THE SAME QUESTION I ASKED- MS
KALLIO IN THEN- MR BACK YOU CAN
BE PREPARED SOMEONE ASK YOU THE
NEXT QUESTION BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT ONE IS HAVE
REPEALED- HAS THE ABILITY OF
WINE TO SHIP DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS IMPACTED THE NUMBER OF
JOBS AVAILABLE. R. I CAN'T SAY
THAT ON BEHALF OF BEER I HAVE AN
ANSWER A QUESTION I APOLOGIZE I
CAN FOLLOW UP. YEAH I THINK I
THINK IF YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE TODAY IS WE HAVE
A CONCRETE EXAMPLE I JUST WANT
TO MAKE CLEAR. WE GOT A CONCRETE
EXAMPLE OF WHAT IS WORKING WITH
DIRECT TO CONSUMER IN OUR
COUNTRY IN OUR STATE. IT'S SO AS
WE- TRANSFER THE OLD MOVE DOWN
THE LINE AND START TALKING TO
PEOPLE AND WE'VE HEARD A LOT
TODAY. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU LOOK AT THESE THINGS AND ARE
ABLE TO COMMENT DIRECTLY ON THAT
MR BACK DO YOU HAVE A- IN THE
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I DO NOT- BUT I CAN SAY
IT IN THE TIME OF BEING A SALES
PERSON. WHEN I WAS A SALES
PERSON- WE WORK HAND IN HAND
WITH ALL OF THE DISTILLERS AND
SUPPLIERS- TO GET PRODUCT THAT
THEY NEEDED TO THE MARKET- I EAT
INNOVATIVE BRANDS ANY BRAND NEW
GRAPE VODKA BUT WHATEVER THEY'D
CREATED IT WAS OUR JOB TO GET IT
OUT INTO THE MARKET AND WE WERE
VERY SUCCESSFUL AT IT I HAD A
VERY GOOD LIVING. SELLING BRANDS
THAT THEY PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO SELL AT THEIR OWN
FACILITIES OUT IN THE MARKET
PLACE- IF THAT HELPS IT I KNOW
DOESN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION- BUT
I JUST DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT HOUSE SO I THINK FOR THIS
PANEL THAT SOMETHING THAT- WHAT
WE NEED TO HAVE SOME FURTHER
DIALOGUE ON- AS WE GO FORWARD
CERTAINLY SENATOR ALLEN'S GONNA
BE INTERESTED IN HEARING OUR
THOUGHTS AS- THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL BECAUSE THAT. IS
YOU KNOW FOR KIND OF A SHINING
EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING
HERE AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE HEARD TODAY AND SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO GET YOUR
VOICE ON THIS ISSUE. ON THE ON
ON ON THE SPECIFIC ISSUES OF HEY
IF IT'S WORK FOR THIS HOW DO YOU
SEE IT'S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
WITH SPIRITS HOW DO YOU SEE IT'S
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT WITH BEER
SO THANK YOU ALL OF YOU ALL FOUR
OF YOU. FOR BEING WITH US ON
THIS- HEARING AND THANKS FOR
BEING ON VIRTUALLY AND WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ANYONE WANTING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. NOW DO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTHY HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS ALL B. LU LIMITING THE
TESTIMONY TO TWO MINUTES PER
PERSON. LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IT FOR TWO OR
THREE. I SEE ANYBODY WANNA
WISHING HERE NO NOBODY'S COMING
UP. ARE THERE WITNESSES IN TWO
OH FORO. NO THEY NOBODY THERE.
THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC- COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BEGIN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT VIA THE PHONE PRESS
ONE IT'S BEEN ZERO NOW AND THE
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU A LINE
NUMBER WHICH WILL CALL YOU BY
THAT NUMBER. AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT BEFORE OUR FIRST COMMENT
AND WE HAVE ABOUT SEVEN IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WELFARE. YOU'RE VERY WELCOME
FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN'T PLEASE
PRESS YES. HI THIS IS STEPHEN
HARRISON I'M WITH MARYLAND
MARKET WE PROVIDE A PLATFORM AT
THE PRODUCE IS DOING ACT CLIENT
BAND AND HE COMMENTS THE
TEACHING SALES. REPRESENT ABOUT
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED SMALL
PRODUCERS AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
WE ARE LOOKING FOR AND HAVE A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN THIS AGE
VERIFICATION. AND PASS THE
OPPORTUNITY THAN THAT USING THE
ELECTRONIC AGE VERIFICATION SUCH
AS IDEOLOGY AND BEADS ARE USED
IN A NUMBER OF STATES LIKE
MASSACHUSETTS MARYLAND CORRECT
THAT THE CRACKS ME PRE
AUTHORIZING. AGE VERIFICATION
CRACKING SHIPMENT AND THEN OF
COURSE THE SHIP THAT DOES IT ON.
THE LIVERY THE OTHER BIG TOPIC
THAT COMES UP IS THAT TAX
COLLECTION WITH THAT OVER FORTY
STATES NOW HAVING IMPLEMENTED
MARKET PLACE A DELIBERATE ATTACK
THE FAILED CRACKED. AND THE
COLLECTION OF SALES TAX THAT
MUCH EASIER THE STATE AND
THEY'RE GETTING IT AND WE ARE
ONE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ENSURE THAT THE SALES TAX IS
COLLECTED. SO THAT MANY SYSTEMS
THAT ARE IN PLAY AM I DO HEAR
ABOUT THE ELECTED. COUNTERFEIT
PRODUCTS AND WHICH MEANS THAT A
LITTLE STRANGE COMMENT ON IT
COMING BACK RIGHT. FROM. THE APP
PREVIEWS THE- DANA. AND THEN YOU
KNOW THE XTERRA AND DO YOU OF
TECHNOLOGY THE IN THE I IS-
EIGHT AND TO THE- AND YOU KNOW
WE ARE BEING AND IF. IN OTHER.
NOW COMING INTO THE BIG PICTURE. QUESTION THERE ARE. LOOKING
DATE THAT ALLOWING INTEREST
ARRAY. AND THUS NUMBER THAT
ALLOWED INTO STATE. AND YOU KNOW
THE JOB QUESTION THAT'S BEEN
TALKED ABOUT WEEKS PLEASE WRAP
UP THE ROAD IN. PIECES AND
ANYWAY WE'RE HERE AND AVAILABLE
TO ADD COMMENT AGAIN WE USE WE
WORK WITH TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
PRODUCERS AROUND THE COUNTRY ON
GPC. AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE OVER THE FIFTEEN
YEARS WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME APPRECIATE. ME ACTUALLY
LISTENING TO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT. MAG SILVER TO LINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TWENTY ONE. HELLO THEY GIVEN ANY
DATA SPIEGEL AND I'M THE CEO
ACCORDING TO THE DISTILLERS AND
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND TEN I
WANT MY BRAND NUMBER BILLING
COMPANY AND WE ARE CURRENTLY FOR
SALE IN PENN STATE THE FIFTEEN
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD. THAT
BRAND RELIES ON WHISKEY MADE
FROM MAJORITY GRANGE FROM
CALIFORNIA GROWERS A CALIFORNIA
FARMERS WHEN OUR TEACHER WITH
OPEN WE HAD ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IN
SALES. ON SITE SALES ONE CALL
THAT HIT THAT ONE DOWN TO ZERO
TODAY WOULD BE EASY SHIPPING
ADDRESS TO CONSUMER SALES BUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR YEAR TO DATE. AND
WE STILL DON'T HAVE AN OPEN DATE
. WHEN WE TOOK CONTROL OF THEIR
CASE AROUND WE THE CHANCE TO
CONTINUE. OUR OVERALL BEEP BEEP
UP. R. CREEK- NUMBERS OUR TODAY.
IT WENT OVER A HUNDRED DOWN
UNDER FIFTY THOUSAND IN DTC
SALES. DEPARTMENT KNOW THAT PC
MAKES UP ONLY TEN PERCENT. OF
OUR OVERALL SALES THE MAJORITY
GOES THROUGH DISTRIBUTION. OR
MOST IMPORTANT AFTER THE DTC IS
PROVIDE US THE ABILITY TO SELL
SPECIAL RELEASES. AND ONE OFF
PRODUCTS ARE DISTRIBUTORS HAVE
CHOSEN NOT TO TAKE UP. ANY CLEAR
THEY OFTEN CHOOSE NOT TO CARRY
SMALL BATCH OR NEW STYLE
PRODUCTS. TRULY DEEPLY SEASON
INCUBATOR. STORY LIKE MINE. WE
CAN CONNECT WITH THE CONSUMERS
IN A WAY THAT ALL OUT AND FINE
TUNE OUR PRODUCTS. AND DO OUR
JOB RIGHT WE CAN NOT GET BENCI
PROVIDED THROUGH DISTRIBUTION OF
THE SPECIAL TO RELEASE WORTH
SELLING. THROUGH THE WHOLESALE
CHANNEL. ELEVEN WORKING ONE
COUNTRY CAN TELL YOU FIRSTHAND
HOW MUCH PRESIDENT AND EASY TO
DTT PLATFORM IS FOR THE WINE
INDUSTRY. I BELIEVE IT MADE THE
WIND INDUSTRY EXACTLY WHAT IT IS
TODAY. I'M SEVENTY FOUR LIKE A
P. TODAY WELL MY COMPANY'S
GROWTH WE ANTICIPATE BEING
ATTACKED FOR SOMETIME IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO. I HOPE THAT
REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
DISTILLERY. THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE
A GOOD CHANCE TO CONTINUE SELL
BOTTLED DIRECTLY. WITHIN OUR
STATE I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS. MEASURE I THINK.
SIX TWENTY. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR SPIEGEL- NEXT WEEK-
THANKS FOR OF TELLING THIRTY
FIVE AGAIN LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE GERMAN GOD
MEMBERS OF BOAT BUILDER WITH
PLATINUM ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
BRUCE DOUBLED THE MACRO A. AND
U. P. S. LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS- TODAY SO TODAY'S
CONSUMERS WANT ENHANCED
CONVENIENCE WHEN IT COMES TO
PURCHASING THEIR FAVORITE
PRODUCTS. INCLUDING DISTILLED
SPIRITS WHETHER PRODUCED IN
STATE OUT OF STATE OR OUTSIDE
THE U. S. IN RECENT YEARS THE
WORLD OF COMMERCE HAS CHANGED
AND WILL CONTINUE TO CHANGE
DRAMATICALLY. PARTICULARLY IN
THE WAKE OF THE NINETEEN.
MARKETS MUST ADAPT TO MEET
CONSUMER DEMANDS ALLOWING
DISTILLERS AND IMPORTERS SHIP
DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS WOULD HELP
MEET THIS CONSUMER DEMAND WHILE
ACTING AS A COMPLEMENT. TO THE
THREE TIER SYSTEM FOR BEVERAGE
ALCOHOL BUT ALSO JUST LIKE TO
ADD THAT U. P. S. IN CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYS NEARLY FORTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS AND ALSO HAPPENS TO
BE THE WORLD'S LARGEST EMPLOYER
TEAMSTERS. THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME MISTER CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT BEAKER. MAXIMO
TIELINE FOURTEEN AGAIN LINE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GREAT
THANK YOU DEAR GOD AND THE OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
PHIL MCDANIEL ON THE CEO AND CO
FOUNDER ST AUGUSTINE DISTILLERY
IN FLORIDA I'M ALSO THE CHAIR OF
THE CRAFT ADVISORY COUNCIL FOR
DISCUSSION AND DISCUSS IN
CONCERT WITH THE AMERICAN CRAFT
SPIRITS ASSOCIATION AND THE
AMERICAN DISTILLING AS-
EXCEEDING AMERICAN DISTILLING
INSTITUTE HELP REPRESENT BALKED
AT THE BILL OF OVER TWO THOUSAND
FAMILY OWNED AND OPERATED CRAFT
DISTILLERIES. ARE COMPANIES IN
AUGUST IN THE STORE IS LOCATED
IN THE HISTORIC SAINT AUGUSTINE
FLORIDA THE NATION'S OFFICE CITY
TOURISM IS OUR CITY'S LARGEST
INDUSTRY IN THE CITY HOSTS
BETWEEN SIX AND EIGHT MILLION
VISITORS A YEAR TEN YEARS AGO WE
BUILT ONE OF THE FIRST CRAFT
DISTILLERIES IN THE STATE AND
STARTED PRODUCING THE FIRST.
BOURBON WHISKEY MADE IN FLORIDA
. WE ARE HIGHLY. THIS AND SINCE-
OPENING WE CALL OVER A MILLION.
FROM AROUND THE WORLD WE
ESTIMATE BETWEEN FIVE AND 6% OF
OUR VISITORS COME FROM
CALIFORNIA OR AN ESTIMATED SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND GUESTS SINCE
OPENING. HE'S GOT COMMAND THEY
TAKE A TOUR THEY SEE ARE STILLS
ARE PERILS ARE HAND BOTTLING A
SAMPLER SPIRITS. THEY GO TO THE
GIFT SHOP THEY'RE ALL EXCITED
AND READY TO PURCHASE THE
MISTAKE WE SHIP THESE BACK TO MY
HOME IN CALIFORNIA- DISAPPOINTED
WHEN OUR STAFF GIVES HIM THE BAD
NEWS BUT WE CAN'T SHIP THE
CALIFORNIA. LEAVE EMPTY HANDED
FRUSTRATED NO WORSE- THEY'VE
LOST THEIR NEW FAVORITE WHISKEY
AND WE'VE LOST A CUSTOMER. WHAT
MAKES IT EVEN MORE CHALLENGING
AND FRUSTRATING FOR THESE
CALIFORNIA GUESTS AS MANY OF
THEM COME TO US AFTER HAVING
JUST VISITED A LOCAL WINERY JUST
A FEW BLOCKS AWAY. WHERE THEY'VE
HAD A SIMILAR TOUR AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO PURCHASE AND ARRANGED TO
HAVE THEIR ONE SHIP BACK HOME.
THEY SIMPLY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THIS DOUBLE STANDARD WHY THEY
CAN GET ONE SHIP BUT NOT
SPIRITS. AND WHILE I REPRESENT
JUST ONE BUSINESS OUR EXPERIENCE
AND STORY IS REPEATED ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND THEY PUT AN
ENGAGED AND INTERESTED CONSUMERS
FROM CALIFORNIA WHO WANT TO
EXPERIENCE SMALL BATCH. AND
LIMITED PRODUCTION PRODUCTS LIKE
CARS. THREE QUICK POINTS I WANT
TO MAKE BEFORE I CLOSE I'D LIKE
TO GO ON RECORD IN SAYING IT'S
PART OF MY TESTIMONY TODAY THAT
ONE. EVERY CRAFT DISTILLERY THAT
I'VE SPOKEN TO IS FULLY
DEDICATED TO ENSURING THAT NO
UNDERAGE SALES TO MINORS. AND
THEY WILL CALL BEST PRACTICES
FROM THE WINE INDUSTRY IN COMMON
CARRIERS. TO THEY WILL WORK
DILIGENTLY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
APPROPRIATE TAX ARE COLLECTED.
THREE BTC IS ABSOLUTELY
COMPLEMENTARY TO AND SUPPORTS
THE THREE TIER SYSTEM. AND FOCUS
MALL BRANDS LIKE OURS AND MANY
OTHER CRAFTS IT'S AN ON RAMP FOR
US. LOOKING TO EXPAND TO OTHER
MARKETS. ON BEHALF OF OUR
EMPLOYEE FELLOW CRAFT. A THE-
AND PERHAPS IMPORTANTLY IN
RELEVANT TO THIS COMMITTEE THE
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
GAS WHO POSTED. I WILL CLOSE IN
THE FUTURE. WE THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THIS MATTER WE URGE YOU.
TO PASS THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT BEAKER.
THANKS A LOT TO LINE SEVENTEEN
AGAIN MINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN DIED
IN COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR GIVING
ME THIS CHANCE TO TALK I AM
GETTING A BARBER FOUNDER OF THE
HOUSE THE SELLER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN I STARTED MY
DISTILLERY THERE WERE NO MORE
THAN FIVE SMALL DISTILLERIES IN
CALIFORNIA BOMB MAKING BRANDY BY
THE WAY CALIFORNIA WAS THE NEXUS
AND FOUNDATION FOR THE CRAFT
SPIRITS MOVEMENT AROUND THE
COUNTRY- BUT TODAY WE FIND
OURSELVES A LITTLE BIT LAGGING
IN TERMS OF MODERNIZATION- OF
OUR ABILITY. TO SELL TO
CONSUMERS. WHEN I STARTED THERE
WAS NOT EVEN A INKLING OF A
DREAM THAT WE'D BE ABLE TO SELL
DIRECT TO CONSUMER- WE DIDN'T
HAVE A CRAPPY. LIFE THAN I AM HI
OR BUY OFF THE WHOLE THE
WINEGROWERS LIGHT THE MY FARM
OVER. SIXTY ACRES OF WINE GRAPES
MY- PRODUCT IS SOLD THE BRANDY
WINE MAKER FOR THE DISTILLER
SECOND. I HAVE THE RIGHT TO SELL
DIRECT TO CONSUMER AND ACTUALLY
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
LICENSEE TYPE THE CALIFORNIA
BRANDY MANUFACTURERS WHO CAN
SELL THEIR PRODUCTS AND HAVE
BEEN SELLING THEIR PRODUCT.
DIRECT TO CONSUMER WITHIN THE
STATE. REALLY WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR TODAY IS JUST PARITY AMONG
ALL THE DIFFERENT LICENSEES SO
THAT THEY CAN ENJOY THE SAME
RIGHTS THAT WINE GROWERS- AND
ACTUALLY EVERY WINE GROWER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS THE
RIGHT TO SHIP. BRANDY AND BRANDY
ONLY DIRECT TO CONSUMER WITHIN
THE STATE. SO WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT GROWING THE POT.
AND DIRECT TO CONSUMER ALLOWING
. BILLER THINK HOW. ACCESS TO
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS WILL
GROW OUR INDUSTRY LIKE. NO
OTHER- IF YOU LOOK GOOD AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT SIX
TWENTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. AND IF
THEY HAVE AN UPDATE WE NOW HAVE
ABOUT TEN MORE IN THE QUEUE WILL
NEXT MOVE TO LINE TWENTY FOUR
AGAIN NINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THE CHAIRMAN
THANK THE COMMITTEE PLAYING
SPEAK MY NAME IS CARSON BENOWITZ
FREDERICKS AND RESEARCH DIRECTOR
ALCOHOL JUSTICE BEEN REBEL. I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO EXPANSION DIRECT DELIVERY- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT- DIRECT DELIVERY
IS GOING TO MAKE IT MUCH MORE
LIKELY THAT ALL SALES WILL OCCUR
WITHOUT- ANY ABILITY TO MONITOR
OR- ENGAGE RESPONSIBLE BEVERAGE
SERVICE PRACTICES- IT'S- USUALLY
THAT. INCLUDES THAT- FAILURES TO
CARD RECIPIENTS- AND ALSO-
DURING CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE IT'S
BEING SOLD SOMEBODY WAS
DANGEROUSLY INTOXICATED OR
OTHERWISE ENGAGE IT RECEIVED.
THAT PRODUCTS ARE- MOREOVER IT-
DRAFT CANCER CAL THE ONLY TO
SEND ENFORCE REGULATIONS WHEN
YOU END UP HAVING- THAT
NATIONWIDE DIRECT DELIVERY ARE
THERE IF THEY ALREADY AN EXAMPLE
OF THIS WHICH IS THAT IF YOU GO
TO- MAN AT AN ONLINE MARKETPLACE
FOR ALCOHOL. ROB SIXTY FIVE
WARNING BECAUSE THAT THE CANCER
WARNING THAT WE ARE ALL VERY
FAMILIAR SEEING IN EVERY CORNER
STORE. HI IT'S TURNED INTO A-
OPT IN LINK CLICK HERE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO VIEW THIS MORNING AND
THAT IS. EVENTUALLY- AND IN A
WAY TO IGNORE CALIFORNIA'S
SOVEREIGNTY AND IN TERMS OF
SETTING. THAT PARTICULAR WARNING
STANDARD. ARE THE- AREA STILL
YOU CAN EITHER SIDE THE
SPIRALING INTO AN INABILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO- THAT ANY.
STANDARD- MORE THAN THAT ALSO WE
HEAR THAT THIS BILL IF IT WORKS
AS ADVERTISED WILL RESULT IN-
OVERALL INCREASE IN SALES OF
ALCOHOL TO CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS-
THAT THERE IS KIND OF NO WAY FOR
THIS TO NOT HARM ANY ANY. OTHER
BUSINESS FACTOR IN THIS FACTOR
WITHOUT NEEDING THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE DRINKING MORE.
AND WE'RE GONNA BE WE AS WE ARE
EVERY TIME WE'RE GOING TO BE THE
VOICE OF REASON HERE WHICH IS
THAT ALCOHOL HARM IS BEEN ON A
STEADY CLIMB IN THE STATE FOR
TWENTY YEARS. ALL WE HAVE SEEN
A- 50% INCREASE IN DIAGNOSES IN
ALCOHOL USE DISORDER IN IN THIS
COUNTRY IN TWO THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND WE HAVE SEEN A DRASTIC
INCREASE IN DEATHS FROM LIVER
DISEASE WE HAVE SEEN- IT AND- A
REMARKABLE AMOUNT OF THAT HAS
BEEN CONCRETE IN YOUNG.
CONSUMERS THAT MEANS THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST. A FUNCTION OF THE
POPULAR- COULD YOU PLEASE WRAP
UP I'LL GIVE THEM MORE TIME
BECAUSE I THINK YOUR VIEWPOINT
IS WORK THAT HAD BEEN MISSED
HERE AND SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. YOU ARE JUST
GOING TO. SAY I'M JUST GOING TO
GIVE THE PRICE TAG IS FOURTEEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR. THE
COST FROM ALCOHOL FORM. THAT WE
CAN DO THAT IN CANADA SURE
SURELY GONE UP IN THE DECADE
FAN. AND AGAIN WE ASK THAT YOU-
ARE. READING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY- THE CLIENT THIS
EXPANSION AND- DELIVERY PROJECT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS APPRECIATE IT
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MAXIMO
CAROLINE FORTY THREE AGAIN NINE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- THIS IS
JOE LANG REPRESENTING REPUBLIC
NATIONAL DISTRIBUTING-
PREVIOUSLY KNOWN I THINK HERE IS
YOUNG'S MARKET COMPANY FOR OVER
A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THE TIME TO CHAT- A
COUPLE OF IMPORTANT POINTS I
THINK ONE I LIKED HIM MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT AS WHOLESALERS HERE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE SENSITIVE TO
THE NEEDS OF SMALL DISTILLERS TO
CALIFORNIA. WE WORKED OVER THE
YEARS TO HELP THEM HELP THEM GET
THEIR PRODUCTS TO MARKET BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY THEY ARE OUR FUTURE
CUSTOMERS AND THE FUTURE.
PRODUCTS THAT WE WILL DISTRIBUTE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SURE WE
WORKED WITH THEM IN THE PAST A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT PIECES OF
LEGISLATION- HELPING THEM TO
GROW. HOWEVER ALLOWING LARGE OUT
OF STATE SELLERS TO SHIP
DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT
MAP. THERE IS REALLY IN FACT NO
DEMONSTRATED NEED TO MAKE THIS
CHANGE FOR LARGE OUT OF STATE TO
STORES- THEY'RE NOT HURTING BUT
THEY WEREN'T IMPACTED BY CODED.
AS FOR OUR SMALL CALIFORNIA
DISTILLERS HERE AND SO WE NEED
AND WE THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE A DISTINCTION.
BETWEEN OUR SMALL CALIFORNIA
BASED DISTILLERS AND THE NEED TO
HELP FOSTER AND FACILITATE THEIR
GROWTH VERSUS LARGE OUT OF STATE
THE SELLER'S SHIPPING DIRECTLY
TO CALIFORNIA. TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION MISTER CAIR DIRECTLY
ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE WITH WINE
THE REPORT DID NOTE THAT WINE
ACTUALLY THE PRIVILEGE TO SHIP
TO CONSUMERS WAS DEVELOPED OVER
DECADES AS PART OF. THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION RECOGNIZING THE WINE
IN FACT IS THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS. THE
SYSTEM THE RETAIL SYSTEM THE
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM SYSTEM
PERFECT SHE GREW UP WITH THAT
PRIVILEGE. THAT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATION THAN THE
CASE WITH DISTILLED SPIRITS WERE
THE CHANGE THE- CONTEMPLATED
HERE. WOULD BE A COMPLETE CHANGE
FROM THE SYSTEM THAT EXISTS
RIGHT NOW AND THEN BECAUSE OF A
WHOLE VARIETY OF DISRUPTIONS PUT
JOBS AT RISK. BOTH AT THE
WHOLESALE LEVEL AND AT THE
RETAIL LEVEL SO I THINK. THE
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION VERY
DIFFERENT VERY DIFFERENT IN
TERMS OF HOW THE INDUSTRY'S
DEVELOPED AND EVOLVED AND WHILE
. THE INDUSTRIES OF THE WHOLE
WHOLESALERS RETAILERS HAVE GROWN
WITH THE WINE INDUSTRY AND IT'S
BEEN TO THE BENEFIT OF ALL THE
SITUATION WITH DISTILLED SPIRITS
THAT IMPACT THE VERY DIFFERENT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN APPRECIATE
THE TIME THANKS MR LYING NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MAXIMUM OF TEN
NINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE THIRTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
A CHAIR AND MEMBERS HERE TODAY
MY NAME IS MINA JIMENEZ I AM
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE AND WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THE DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIFTING
LEGISLATION BECAUSE OF WHAT WAS
ALREADY UP PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED-
MATERNITY LEAVE A COMMENT THAT
WAS MADE BY THE SPEAKER I THINK
THAT IT IS. DEFINITELY A
DIFFERENT BALL GAME WHEN IT
COMES TO THE DISTILLERS WITH
EXPERIENCE- ANYTHING NOW WITHIN
A SIMILAR TIME LINE AND WE'D
LOOK CRITICALLY AT THAT- BUT WE
HAVE PARTICULAR CONCERNS OVER
THE LACK OF OVERSIGHT I'M FOR
COMPLIANCE- WERE ALREADY HAVING
EXISTING ARCHIVE HAD EXISTING
CHALLENGES WITH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT IN ADDITION. TO THE
INCREASING COSTS RELATED TO
ALCOHOL HARMS THAT ALREADY
EXISTS I PRAY IT PRIOR TO COVERT
NINETEEN WIDE- IN CALIFORNIA WE
DO LIKE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH EIGHTY P.
DEPARTMENT WHO'S BEEN ONGOING-
HAVING ONGOING CHALLENGES WITH
ENSURING COMPLIANCE. FOR ON SITE
ALSO LICENSEES ALREADY WAVING IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE COUNTRY WE HAD-A 70% NONCOMPLIANCE RATE FOR
SERVING ALCOHOL TO MINORS THE
THIRD PARTY ALCOHOL DELIVERY
COMPANIES BUT WE HAVE HAD
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES WITH
ENSURING COMPLIANCE LET ALONE AN
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF CHALLENGES
WITH IT SHIPPING DIRECTLY EVEN
INCLUDING NOW NATIONAL LEVEL.
SHIFTING- OKAY A REALLY PRETTY
POINT TO BECOME- THAT WE WANT
BRING THE- TO DO. IT AROUND THAT
ANGLE OF WHAT DO WE HAVE TO DO
THAT- WE ALSO WANT CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE PUBLIC SPACE WE
CONTINUING. CONTINUE TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW TO COMPLAIN
LOUDLY SHARING IT DISREGARDING
THE EXISTING **** ABOUT THE
HARM. WE KNOW THAT THE CDC
PARTLY COVERED NINETEEN WAS
ALREADY- NOTING- THE COST TO THE
ARCADE AS THIRTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR THAT'S NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLARS PER
PERSON. TWO DOLLARS AND FORTY
CENTS PER DRINK IN TERMS OF
ALCOHOL HARM DISTANT EDP DATA
AND WE ARE COMPLETELY
DISREGARDING. THAT FACT THAT WE
ALREADY KNOW THE EXISTING COST
OF HARM BUT THE PRIOR TO COVER
NINETEEN. AND THERE'S BEEN MUCH
CONVERSATION IN THE COURT ABOUT
THE POLITICAL CONTENT OF THE
BILL ABOUT HOW A LOT MORE
ALCOHOL WILL BE SOLD BUT NOT
ENOUGH EMPHASIS IS FOCUSED ON
HOW DO YOU SPELL. IMPACT ON REAL
PEOPLE YOUR CHILDREN YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN EVEN FAMILY
MEMBERS IMPACTED BY. YOU AND
THOUGHT WELL TELL. CAN YOU
PLEASE WRAP UP. YOUR OVER
WRAPPING UP. WE THINK SOME. IN
RESOLVED IN PEOPLE HAVING A LOT
MORE ALCOHOL CONTENT. AND THIS
IS INCREASE OUR BONITA
RECOGNIZED THE COLD NINETEEN.
WALLET IN THE BUSINESS OF THE-
IN. PEOPLE AND IS SOMETHING THAT
WE TO LOOK CRITICALLY AT WORK
FIRST OF PEOPLE FORTY INCREASED
DRINKING DURING THE ACADEMIC
THANK YOU KNOW YOU REALLY NEED
TO LOOK AT THE MARKET. VERY MUCH
NEXT SPEAKER. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU.
THAT NICER MOTEL LINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF COMMUNITY
THIS IS PEAK DOWNS. RESIDENTS
FAMILY WINEMAKERS CALIFORNIA.
WELL I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF
BECAUSE I KNOW WE'RE CONSTRAINED
BY TIME. MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT
VANGUARD RECORDS WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING THE
GRAND HOME PAGE TO THE SUPREME
COURT. HAVING EXCEPTIONAL HOW
COME THERE. I CAN I CAN CHOOSE-
MADE A POINT EARLIER THAT I CAN
REINFORCE CERTAINLY AND THAT IS
BECAUSE MANY OF MY MEMBERS ARE
SO SMALL. HELLO THERE WOULD BE
SOME OF THOSE MEMBERS THAT WOULD
NO LONGER BE WITH US WITHOUT
DIRECT TO CONSUMER SHIPMENTS IT
REALLY WAS A LIFESAVER FOR MANY
MANY SMALL WINERIES AS I'M SURE
IT WILL BE FOR THE AIRCRAFT
BURST IN PARTITION TO STROLLERS. THE OTHER POINT I WANT TO
MAKE- SENATOR DODD IS THAT. B.
DISTRICT CURRENT DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM TRICKED YOUR SYSTEM
REALLY DOESN'T WORK FOR SMALL
WINERIES. AND I SUSPECT IT ISN'T
WORKING WELL FOR THE PREPARATION
. ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WELL AND
THE REASON FOR THAT IS THAT.
WHOLESALER CONSOLIDATION HAS
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST DECADE
AND THE SMALL WINERIES THAT AT
ONE POINT. MIGHT HAVE A CHANCE
TO GETTING DISTRIBUTION THROUGH
THE STRINGERS THAT IS
SUBSTANTIALLY IN THAT AREA. SO I
WOULD SAY THAT- EMILY WINEMAKERS
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT JUST.
CURRENT LEGISLATION. ON BEHALF
OF ALL THOSE SMALL LOCAL
BUSINESSES NOT JUST THE ONE
CHARACTERS BUT THE BREWERS AND
DISTILLERS THANK YOU SURE THANK
YOU MR DOWNS NEXT WEEK PLEASE.
IN MAXIMO TO LINE FORTY TWO
AGAIN NINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS IS
PATRICIA SWANSON CHAIRMAN OF
SHELTER DISTILLING IN MAMMOTH
LAKES CALIFORNIA SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF CONTINUED BPC
SHIPPING. SHELTER DISTILLING
OPENED ITS DOORS IN DECEMBER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN OUR ANNUAL
SALES WILL REACH TWO AND A HALF
MILLION THIS YEAR AND WE EMPLOY
THIRTY PEOPLE. AT THE TRUE FOR
SO MANY HOSPITALITY BUSINESSES
THE TWENTY TWENTY COLBERT SHOT
DOWN THE DEVASTATING. THANKS TO
THE ABC AND GOVERNOR THE
EMERGENCY ORDER ENABLING US TO
SHIP PRODUCTS DIRECTLY TO OUR
CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS HELP ENSURE
OUR SURVIVAL NEARLY TWO YEARS
pTO FLOURISH AUGMENTING THE IN
STORE SALES. SINCE OUR
DISTILLERY IS LOCATED IN A
TOURIST DESTINATION THE ABILITY
TO SELL OUR PRODUCTS ONLINE
KEEPS OUR CUSTOMERS ENGAGED LONG
AFTER THEY RETURNED HOME WE CAN
BRING IN REVENUE AND BUILD OUR
BRAND TO THIS IMPORTANT SALES
CHANNEL SH IT ALSO ALLOWS US TO
PROVIDE AN ESSENTIAL SHIPPING
SERVICE FOR CUSTOMERS IN STORE
WHO WANT TO PURCHASE OUR
SPIRITS. BUT ARE NOT ABLE TO
EASILY TRAVEL HOME WITH THEM. AS
AN ASIDE MIS COLEGAS ASSERTION
EARLIER THAT LOCAL LICENSED
RETAIL DELIVERY ISN'T ADEQUATE
ALTERNATIVE P. E. T. C. WELL
THAT DOESN'T WORK FOR
DISTILLERIES LIKE OURS LOCATED
IN TOURIST DESTINATION. THOSE
OPPOSED TO THIS EXPANSION
PROVIDE NO VIABLE OPTIONS FOR
CRAFT DISTILLERS TO REPLACE ITS
IMPORTANT REVENUE STREAM SHOULD
PROVIDE THE CUSTOMER CONVENIENCE
AND IMPORTANTLY THE INCREASED
EMPLOYMENT IT COMES FROM
INCREASED PRODUCTION. EACH
INDIVIDUAL CRAFT DISTILLERY IS
TOO SMALL TO BE PROFITABLE TO
DISTRIBUTORS WE CANNOT SCALE TO
MEET THE DEMAND DISTRIBUTORS
MUST HAVE MAKE PITCHING OUR
PRODUCTS WORTH THEIR EFFORT WE
KNOW BECAUSE WE'VE TRIED. THIS
IS A CLASSIC CHICKEN AND EGG
DILEMMA WITHOUT THE PROMISE OF
DISTRIBUTION WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
EXPAND PRODUCTION YET WITHOUT
EXPANDED PRODUCTION WE CANNOT
MEET THE DEMAND REQUIRED FOR
DISTRIBUTION. THIS IS ALSO.
WHERE DTC SALES CAN HELP WE CAN
INCREASE PER PROFITABLY WELL
BUILDING A BRAND AND TRY ALL.
WHICH ULTIMATELY WILL MAKE US
MORE APPEALING TO DISTRIBUTORS.
FINALLY WINERIES HAVE ENJOYED
THIS BENEFITS SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX AND WE ALL KNOW HOW
VALUABLE THE WINE INDUSTRY IS
THE CALIFORNIA WE ARE SIMPLY
ASKING FOR PARITY WITH OUR
BROTHER IN THE WINE INDUSTRY. SO
PLEASE CONSIDER MAKING DTC SALES
AND SHIPPING PERMANENT. IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT-
I'M JUST GOING TO. YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY BUT MR DOWNS IS KEPT
AT IT I MEAN IT'S BEEN OVER TWO
MINUTES PRACTICALLY TODAY SO I'D
LIKE TO LIKE ALL THE REST OF THE
SPEAKERS IF YOU COULD JUST
CURTAIL YOUR COMMENT TO BE.
SUCCINCT IT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TO- OUR TEAM HERE OUR
STAFF THANK YOU SO MUCH- NEXT
BEAKER. NEXT TO A BOTTOM LINE
SIXTEEN AGAIN NINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO SENATOR
DEL THIS IS TERRY FLANAGAN
REPRESENTING SOUTHERN GLAZER
WINE AND SPIRIT WHOLESALERS AND
AS YOU KNOW YOU'RE AFTER YOUR
SOUTHERN. HAS BEEN FORMATTED
SUPPORT OF A THREE TIER SYSTEM-
SIX OF THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
DIRECT SALES THE DISTILLED
SPIRITS THE CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS
JUST FUNDAMENTALLY UNDERMINES
THE SYSTEM FOR REASONS THAT HAVE
BEEN WELL PRESENTED BY TODAY'S
OPPOSITION PANELS AND I'M NOT
SURE THAT I COULD ADD ANYTHING
ADDITIONAL THE ADDITIONAL POINTS
ON THE BUTTONS. BUT YOU KNOW
THAT SOUTHERN GLACIER. INCLUDE
TO SOFTEN THEIR OPPOSITION. WELL
DONE MR FLANAGAN NEXT BEAKER
THAT'S THE FEDERAL EXPRESS OR
IMPLEMENTATION OF MY
PRESENTATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. I KNOW THAT SOME OF THE
LINE THIRTY NINE LINE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT BROWN IN
THE AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS JUST REALLY QUICKLY
WITH RESPECT TO THE WORK FORCE
ISSUES PRESENTED BY THIS BILL I
JUST WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT ONE'S NOT ALL JOBS ARE
CREATED EQUALLY- AND BY THAT
TOKEN U. P. S. IS A GOOD KEEPS
YOUR EMPLOYER- BUT WE HAVE OTHER
GREAT FUTURE EMPLOYERS LIKE THEY
WANT TO INSPECT IT TODAY- WE
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL AND WHO WOULD BENEFIT. THIS
IS ABOUT THE LITTLE GUY OR DID
WE BENEFIT LARGE OUT OF STATE
SELLERS AT THE COST OF OUR
MEMBERS JOBS AND WHAT SORT OF
JOB THAT YOU CREATE IN THE FIRST
PLACE DID MORE JOBS IN THE GIG
ECONOMY. SO WITH THAT IN MIND WE
WOULD ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THIS
POINT AS WE PREPARE Q.
CEDARVILLE AGAIN NEXT YEAR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR BROAD PER.
SHEET THAT- NEXT WEEK- MAXIMO
THE LINE FOR. LINE FOR. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBERS AND ALL OF THE SHARES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION JUST HEAR ECHO THE
CONCERNS OF THE TEAMSTERS POINTS
IN THE FINAL PANEL AND BY MISTER
BROAD AND OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE ON THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
. WELL DONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER. AND MAXIMO TIELINE
FORTY FIVE AGAIN NINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BONOBOS
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR GIVING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
OPPOSITION OF THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION MY NAME IS ARGHA
ENSEMBLE OF PERCENT FIFTY SEVEN
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES THAT
OWNED BY MY FAMILY. ALL IN THE
FED THEM- PARTS OF THE STATE- WE
ALSO HAVE OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES THEY'RE PART OF OUR
FAMILY THIS LEGISLATION THAT
ONLY WILL DISMANTLE THE CREATIVE
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA BUT THEY
WERE ALSO- BUT WILL BE
DEVASTATING TO ALL OF THESE MOM
AND POP BUSINESSES AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO
THE COVERT NINETEEN CONDEMNING
IT AND WE GIVE A WORD HE WILL
DESTROY CLICK ADMISSION TO THE
FRONTLINE WORKERS BUT YOU KNOW
WHO ELSE WAS ON THE FRONT LINE.
UP I WANT THEM TO BE I KNOW WHAT
I'M FULLY CO PROVIDED ESSENTIAL
SERVICES BREAD MILK AND
EVERYTHING AND EVERY DAY- AND WE
PUT IT ON THAT AND WE TOOK CARE
OF IT. VERY PROUDLY. THIS THIS.
I ONLY HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE-
AS THESE NOTES WHAT'S- THIS BILL
WHO'S GOING TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA. I WANT
FIFTY SEVEN BUSINESSES ALREADY
CRAP THAT'S WE MANDATED TRAINING
THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
A. B. C. B. TRAINING AS A PART
OF A LOT OF. HI I'VE BEEN CROSS
. SO WHO'S GOING TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMER SO PLEASE WE URGE YOU
TO OPPOSE. THE DISMANTLING OF
THE THREE TIER SYSTEM AND- AND
TO PROTECT THE FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS- NEXT BEAKER.
MAXIMUM OF NINE FORTY SIX AGAIN
NINE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IT HAPPENED INSURED MEMBERS THIS
IS DADDY GRANDMA LIKE YOU HAVE
TO W. WESTERN STATE COUNSELED BY
TACKLE THE COMP THAT THAT
COMMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT BEAKER. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT- I'M ONLY. SO I THINK
WITH THAT. I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS FIRST OF
ALL I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT- THAT WAS FORTH
COMING HERE TODAY I THINK- WITH
ALL OUR PANELS- YOU KNOW WE CAN
SEE THAT THIS IS- YEP. YOU KNOW
FRANKLY WHY I LOOK AT THIS BILL
LAST YEAR AND SAID HEY WE NEED
MORE DISCUSSION AND WHY I FELT
LIKE THIS HEARING WAS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY BEFORE WE CONSIDERED
ANY BILL SO I APPRECIATE ALL OUR
SPEAKERS TODAY THAT- THAT- WAR
ON THE PANELS AND OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT- I DO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
GET YOUR COMMENTS INTO OUR
CONSULTANT IN WRITING ANY OF THE
SLIDESAND YOU HAD VERY VERY
INFORMATIVE FRANKLY ON BOTH
SIDES. SO I THINK THAT'S JUST-
DEMONSTRATES THAT THIS IS GONNA
BE A DIFFICULT POLICY AREA-
DECISIONS HAVE NOT BEEN MADE
THIS IS ONE RIGHT NOW THAT- WILL
BE GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
WE APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S-
PARTICIPATION TODAY IN THIS
HEARING SO WITH THAT- I WILL NOW
ADJOURN THE MEETING ON
GOVERNMENTAL COMMITTEE HEARING
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.